Hey everybody,
if you're,
if you're tuning in to this and you're expecting a regular podcast,
this is definitely not a regular podcast.
This is a podcast.
What we sit down and watch the UFC fights and just sort of talk shit while the
fights are going on.
Don't even expect commentary.
Don't expect that either.
Don't expect,
don't expect anything and hopefully you won't have your expectations shattered.
But with me here is uncle creepy in McCall,
one of the top flyweights on the planet earth.
And my brother Jimmy Smith,
one of the best analysts slash MMA commentators slash Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black
belt slash a commentator for Bellator until they changed the name Bella tour.
And it should be like for now,
for now,
still belts for like maybe MMA.
And what we're going to do is we're just going to a talk while the will,
the fights are going on,
there's a UFC fight night that's happening right now live from San Antonio.
And uh,
we'll let you know.
It's hard to sync up because there's a little bit of a delay between the
Internet and what's on television.
I think it's like a 15 second delay.
So what we'll do is we'll just give you like,
fight starts now with us.
And so you'll know when to sync up with the very first fight.
So until then,
it'll be kind of a cluster fuck.
But the card is pretty fucking dope.
I'm very excited about cub Swanson and Jeremy Stevens.
That's a good fucking fight.
I'm not excited about this man.
He's been dogging this since we got in here.
You're friends with both of them and someone's getting their ass kicked at night
and then like,
fuck,
I'm friends with both of them too.
I like both guys tremendously.
I liked them as fighters.
I liked them as people,
but damn,
I want to see them fight.
It's going to be exciting.
Oh good.
No doubt about it.
Impossible to not be right.
There's no way.
And uh,
also,
uh,
Calvin gasoline,
who Miss Weight again?
He's fighting a Nico Moose Skokie.
Who?
Soki how'd he say it was?
Soki whatever you say it.
The dude's Badass.
I've seen him fight.
He's excellent.
Very,
very good fighter.
Um,
he,
uh,
fights out of Sweden.
He's a one of those dudes that trains with Gustafson I believe.
And uh,
he's a very talented,
very talented and very complete all round game.
So that's the,
that's the Co main event and a lot of good fights on the undercard as well.
It's um,
it's live right now from San Antonio,
Texas.
Who else is on there?
Card here.
I'm going to see Diaz versus llamas.
Yes,
that's right.
Ricardo Lamas is on this card,
right?
Yes.
He's fighting Huck Ron Diaz.
He fought an m one.
A covered a few of his fights.
Did you?
Yeah,
he's Novan y'all great Jujitsu,
the nine submissions,
nine and his career.
But he's exactly the kind of guy you want.
If you're Ricardo lumps this camp because he's dangerous.
He's not that well rounded.
There's not a lot of x factor to his game.
You want llamas,
you know,
mentally ready to get back in there.
I thought he had a good fight for the title,
but you want,
you got back on the horse pretty quick and Diaz is the right guy for that.
Yeah.
What did you think of that fight?
Lomis and uh,
and um,
although I think all those,
just on another level,
yeah,
all those,
just for the first two rounds,
he's the baddest motherfucker on earth for the first two rounds.
Do you think it's lazy or do you think you just can't keep,
keep that weight cut?
That weight cuts brutal.
The dude walks around in one,
seven days.
Like I saw a member zeal and Andy plus he just looks like a Predator walking.
I was like,
that guy's book.
What's strange about the Lama side if you look at it,
is that that was a fight where you paste himself pretty well.
Like you know,
he didn't look like he was expanding a ton of energy in the first rounds like it
usually does.
Right.
And yet he still didn't have gas in the first fifth round.
So I think it is the weight cut where it's just he only has so many minutes,
the clock starts no matter what he does.
Cause he didn't do a lot of wild stuff in the beginning and he's still renting a
gas in the fifth round.
Do you remember when he fought?
Not In Toronto.
And they had that enormous car and they had all the fighters up on the deck and
everybody said he was the one who we fight fought hom nick,
he was gonna pass out a so sick.
He was so sick that he couldn't,
he couldn't just sit there,
he couldn't sit that they had to take him off the desk and they had to bring
them downstairs.
And this is before he weighed in,
you know,
I mean it was really,
it's ridiculous to ask a fighter before they weigh in and put a fucking suit on
and strap your belt on and pretend that everything's fine when meanwhile you're
on death's door,
you know,
how much do you cut when you cut weight?
I was one 40 after practice this morning and Ian Fights at 125 pounds,
one of the top hundred 25 pounders on the planet.
So He's,
he knows what the fuck he's talking about.
So one 40 for you and when you get down like the week of the fight,
woody tried away.
I try to walk around under one 41 39 is okay with you.
I'd rather be one 35,
but that's probably not going to happen.
And we need the lighter I get,
the better I fight.
It seems.
Do you drink a shitload of water the week of,
to get your body used to just pumping it out of your system?
Is that the idea of mining distilled?
I mean,
it took us a few days to find distilled water in Brazil,
but we did it.
Yeah.
You have to find distilled water,
right?
Yeah.
Why is that?
No minerals in it.
The minerals,
retaining water strips your body of all the salts and stuff and minerals.
And then,
um,
but most people don't do this.
You have to replenish the body.
But those minerals,
right?
Like if you get that company,
that company called called trace minerals,
that makes trace minerals.
You can,
I put them in my,
my water before I go to bed every night.
Every night while you're trained.
Yeah.
That's a huge thing.
Just for your health.
People don't understand.
And my girlfriend,
she,
uh,
just learned out the hard way.
So she learned out the hard way or she learned the hard way.
Uh,
she,
she works out so hard as yoga hot yoga like every day,
twice a day.
She's kind of crazy.
I know.
She's listening.
I love you crazy in a good way.
It's a very nice,
she's cool.
Crazy.
But uh,
she,
I bought,
I bought her the drops because I know what she's doing.
I mean,
I give her all kinds of stuff,
man.
She does take her vitamins,
but she just does,
is hardheaded and doesn't listen to it.
But now she,
she figured out she needs to take that stuff.
Well,
what made her figure it out?
You said she got sick.
Oh,
she just,
just,
just wasn't feeling good,
you know,
during a practice.
And you think it's because of minerals?
Yeah.
Well,
she sweats out that much and does not drink it.
Doesn't ever try and retain
them.
Well,
that's the thing that they were saying.
Like they had a thing.
Okay,
first fight.
He's going to go on right now.
It's Joe Ellenberger versus James Moon.
Moon,
Moon task three.
Shit,
we probably should have listened outset then task three.
Let's go with one toss free.
Right.
Um,
I never seen this gel and fight in the UFC before.
It must be a one of his,
uh,
first fight.
He hasn't,
he's been fighting really since 2011.
He has had his first and like 2008 or something.
But really since 2011 he's been fighting.
So the asthma seen that long fair,
fairly newbie and Ellenberger is the brother of Jake Ellenberger who is a top
UFC welterweight and Jo Ellen burgers had some serious health issues.
So a,
for him just to get into the UFC,
it was been a,
like a lot of people were saying that he was going to die,
who's going to have a very short lifespan.
He would never be able to fight competitively again.
So to see him get in good enough shape to,
to fight in the UFC is a huge victory for him.
They said he wouldn't live past like 30 or something crazy like that.
Yeah,
I remember seeing a walkout shirt,
if I'm not mistaken,
that I thought he was like on death's door at the time or something.
I forget what it was.
Yeah,
it wasn't good.
At one point in time it was not good.
So whatever his diseases,
the medication costs 440 grand a year,
Jesus and insurance is gonna cover him.
And he's on that right now.
I don't,
I don't know.
I know,
I know that that was the first problem.
Oh my God.
Fucking pharmaceutical companies.
Yeah,
you're going to die soon,
but the medication that'll save you is $440,000.
Yeah.
Let's Jack up some,
uh,
some sound here,
Jamie,
so we could see what's going on here.
It's just nice to see him realize his dream.
You know,
it's gotta be a brutal thing to see your,
your health slip.
Like,
oh,
we just got tagged
as you were.
Yeah.
The,
I mean,
it has to be a young athlete that's,
you know,
on,
just about to get on the big stage.
He's just got signed,
what,
five years ago?
Yeah,
it was quite awhile ago.
This is his first fight.
What do you guys think about that position that keeps coming up over and over
again now?
Uh,
the travel,
I call it the Travis Browne.
When dudes are going for that single and they're clinging onto that leg and they
leave that exposed head and they just get blasted with short turn elbow man.
Woo.
Travis Browne,
throw some heat and those elbows.
He's a big scary person.
Ooh.
That was exactly where to put it.
Exactly where to put it.
He fucking hammer.
Some were repeated.
They're coming down fast and hard.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
By the time the referee gets there,
I mean the referee,
especially if it's a fat referee,
he's got to take three or four steps.
Travis Brown's getting in at least two elbows on an unconscious opponent.
He played by Josh out just out instantly.
No one's ever done that.
Josh,
he Pedro,
his own knocked him out before,
but it was with one perfectly oh cool.
Flying knee attempt there.
Ellen Burger's got a good team.
Weird and Ellenberger.
That's tough.
Yeah,
that knows how to wrestle.
Oh,
look at this
and working on that.
Doris,
knock him his body weight on it though.
Nope.
The struggle.
Now,
if you're fighting a guy who is a late replacement,
like Mutasa fee,
this is how you want to fight where I'm out.
Because if you're finding guys a late replacement,
you have two options.
If you're in Mutasa,
either come in and throw everything you got in the first round or try and
conserve your energy and chose not let them do either one of those.
What was the original opponent?
Do you know?
I don't remember.
I don't remember either,
but Mutasa what did he take this on?
Two weeks notice or something?
Something short.
Okay.
What do you guys think about that?
Touching the hand on the ground to prevent the knees.
That's that man that,
that seems super silly to me.
You can't do it when a strike is headed for you.
Right?
So guys do it really early.
Um,
it's just,
you know,
it's always going to be a tactic.
Can't really get around it.
Well,
last they changed the,
oh,
he got hit hard and you get hit hard.
He does.
Eyes aren't open.
He's really hurt.
Yeah,
he started hard.
His eyes hurt,
nose busted.
I think it's his nose because he can't open his eyes.
Okay.
When Tasha was getting after him,
damn.
Lots of back of the head.
He wins design,
whatever.
Whenever it was that happened,
it was pretty fucking serious.
It looked like it popped his nose.
I think.
Well,
we'll,
we'll probably get a shot at in between rounds,
but Mutasa furry is punching and he's just covering up here,
holding on,
lost the single
and he goes to his back.
He looks like he's all right.
You see blood.
I thought I saw think it's from the nose.
Yep.
Yup.
Let's see.
Ellenberger is guard.
Oh,
exposed knows too.
Yeah.
This his nose.
His nose is bad.
Your vision completely goes when that happens.
Completely.
Okay.
Staying aggressive.
But
this is where it's super important to have a guard.
There's so many guys that just don't ever think they're going to be on their
back.
No,
they,
it's,
come on Sophie,
do you see somebody off their back and you're like,
wow,
like you don't know what you're doing.
I have no idea what you're doing.
You're completely lost.
I've talked to guys who were top level guys and they're like,
man,
I'm not going to be on my back.
I'm like,
okay,
well you hope you're not going to be on your back and I hope for you,
you're not going to be on your back.
But if you fighting somebody like you,
don't you think you could probably put you on your back?
Yeah.
Well there's use out there then they're not the only one.
Right.
It's like the idea of acting like you're the only guy that can do a certain
thing.
That's crazy.
Like thinking you're the only guy that can take you down.
You take guys down so you're going to be on top always.
That seems unlikely.
There's no weapon in MMA you don't need.
Absolutely.
When I,
it's funny,
when you talk to guys and you're in the gym and they go out to,
I don't want to,
I don't want to know that,
and I went,
it's like going into war and going,
I don't need grenades.
I'll never,
I'll never be in the situation where I need a grenade,
a band at a in that fight fighter on how to get up close.
I want to look them in the went dude.
A life.
I'm a sniper.
I don't need a grenade.
Well that you're going to be in that position where you go,
God,
I just wish I had a grenade right now.
Exactly.
Especially mentality,
man.
Yup.
Alan burgers.
Yeah.
His nose is fucked.
Oh.
Mutasa his mom.
Good hip escape.
A lot of guys don't have to have shitty sweeps in half guard.
Like his goto deep half here.
He's just sorta La langue Langer and around lingering around the in his half
guard.
You need,
she'd be sucking up to that guy's body.
But I think Ellenberger is hurt here.
I think he's still trying to recover.
Half Guard is one of the things you see all the time and high level Jujitsu.
They have outstanding half cards and you almost never see a good half guard in
MMA.
So true guards and half guard or just anything off your back.
It's is it punches and elbows is,
I mean it's gotta be what it is.
Guys don't want to get punched in elbows.
They just want to hold.
I want to submit somebody,
I mean it's,
it's an option.
It's like Daniel Cormier was saying,
we were talking before this thing started that cornea and Dominick Cruz are
fucking killing it as analysts.
I love listening to those guys talk and their insight,
but one of the things that they were talking about,
the main event cubs cub,
Swanson and Jeremy Stephens was that Jeremy Stevens has got to be a little bit
more unpredictable.
It's got to throw a few more variables into the mix,
like take down attempts and things along those lines.
And I've always said that that's like,
even if you don't want to take a guy down,
if you think if you make it,
I think that you're trying to take him down,
then he has to think about that and it's one more piece of information has to
process.
If you're only making a guy process stand up,
it's infinitely easier.
It's so much easier.
It's the main reason why George St Pierre was so successful beside the fact that
he's a bad motherfucker.
He was one of the very best at,
you didn't know what was going on.
He didn't know if he was going to try to take you down,
if he's going to stand up with you and the comfort level that he had because he
had fought so many championship fights.
He'd been there,
done that many times.
So you'd see guys,
they'd be in the bright lights.
Holy Shit,
I'm fighting GSP,
and they didn't.
It just didn't know what was common.
And those two factors together combined for an incredible look at this,
they're checking it,
look just right out in burgers.
Eyes look at his right eye.
Justin Bieber's in the cage with them.
Holy Shit.
Okay.
I think they're worried about a fracture when you can't.
A lot of times when the eye drops like that and that's what they're worried
about,
but it looks like the letting them go.
Yeah,
it could be a fracture.
A lot of times it's a fracture of the eye swells up.
Yeah.
And that's a lit drops and they can't really move the eye.
Yeah,
that's what it seems like they're,
wow.
Look at what it looks like.
That's crazy.
Yo.
I've never seen it closed on like that.
It looks weird.
It's like sloths,
man.
You know what it looks like.
It looks like the nerves in his,
I just stopped working like it's not swollen up.
It's just shutting.
It's,
well,
he was wincing for a reason.
He's probably fucked on that side.
He probably can't see left hooks at all though.
Okay.
It's funny,
you know.
Oh Shit.
He's a guy who's going through a situation like Ellenberger as you can't help
but root for them.
But um,
Mutasa Murray,
he's dealing with a great fucking job in this fight is especially on short
notice.
It looks very good.
What's funny to about,
like
we were saying about not,
you know,
not having complete games,
is that something that happens in all combat sports and yet people don't think
it applies him in boxing.
They always say,
if you can't sell the Jab,
I'm not going to buy your right hand if I don't sell.
If you don't sell me on the first one,
you're not going to get the combination.
And people don't think that way in MMA,
which is a little strange.
Yeah.
And you know,
and right here Ellenberger has gotten tossed.
She's back very nice.
And he has a leg in on the cage side,
which is the hard side to get in.
So fucking hard to get a rear naked choke with these goddamn gloves.
Yeah.
For folks who just do Jujitsu,
do yourself a favor one day and do some Oola like I was trapping the arm,
do some Gigi,
got the both hooks and do some Jujitsu with gloves on.
You'll be astounded at.
It makes chokes 20% harder.
20% hard to get.
I went to,
I would take the item with my leg.
Yeah.
I mean,
especially after having Bj do it to me.
Oh,
it's just frightening.
Bj.
So good at that.
He loves getting that rear naked choke.
Trapping the arms.
Yeah,
it's been,
he,
he's only 160 pounds.
I was 150 going out there and he felt so heavy on top.
Was He so good on the ground?
It's just ridiculous.
Yeah.
Bj in his prime was one of the elite of the elite in Jujitsu.
A lot of folks don't know that and he got there quick
first.
Non Brazilian wold champion took it in three years.
Three years.
He got his black belt.
Boom one the one the owls.
He's got the Darce.
Ellenberg got this.
Doris Betty to sit his hip out.
If he pulls this off,
good for it.
He needs it.
You can't help but root for the guy.
Got a lot of space there under that right armpit though,
right?
Is going to give it up?
Yeah.
Oh,
now he's going ducking under it.
Jeff Glover style.
Yes.
Here we go.
Kids a stud.
Oh yeah.
He doesn't have it though.
Nope.
Yeah.
Now he's on top.
Didn't put his hips down.
Do you like the Japanese Necktie?
Do you ever use that?
Okay.
I find them really hard to get really have,
I have really big foreign,
it's really hard for me to get them checked it off so much,
Bro.
Dude,
I can't man.
I'm on the road three months at a time,
Bro.
Three months.
I'm on the road.
Case of a fleshlight.
Oh my God.
He's the Codeword Rogan and say 15 or so.
Ellenberger is still on the bottom here.
Hey Ya.
What did you think of glory?
How fucking awesome was that good man.
It was a fun show to my boys.
Yeah.
Joe Schilling and a Shane of landscape.
Two shillings.
A fucking monster.
He's a monster.
That dude is a beast that knock out of Simon Marcus Oh shit around and he was
spitting it out.
That was a good,
that was a good deduction,
man.
It was big.
Very current deduction.
He knows his shit big.
John McCarthy knows his shit.
The problem with the one day tournament though is a lot to,
it's one by the time the finals rolled around and he's showing me,
she just like,
I have another fight.
Maybe he just didn't have a lot left.
Well,
that's what I hate seeing is when it's decided before.
I mean he walked in there going,
he goes,
I was amazed you can walk to the ring,
but it's not implemented.
Those fights.
Finding three guys in awe.
Imposturous they had Shane come out.
I mean,
granted Shane isn't,
isn't in shape,
ever throws up after every time he works out.
The guy's just really talented,
but he,
from the last punch he threw,
they waited 30 minutes and the,
and that's what they said.
He literally,
you know,
they,
they read that he won,
he walked in the back,
they get changed as gloves and then he walked back out.
And that was,
I mean,
I'm sure Joe's was just as hard.
Wow.
They're savages.
This Shane del Rosario,
is that when you're talking about Shana bonds?
Because Shana.
Okay.
No,
Shane.
Oh,
blondes.
Shane.
Oh,
Blonsky yeah,
he fought and he fought.
He fought in the featherweight.
I need to the finals loss to a Varga.
He's huge at that weight.
I was wake up with him and he missed it and I was fucking pissed.
Any medicine.
I was like so mad.
I don't know how bad the domestic bar two pounds
for the,
for the beginning fighters listening to this,
uh,
nothing will piss off or promoted more than not making weight.
It is pretty much like not showing up for work on like your second day,
you'll get canned fast.
They hate that.
No.
Ian,
obviously you
close to this,
it's hard to look at it objectively,
but do you think that they should abandon weight cutting?
Do you think they should move to abandoned weight cutting.
And do you think it's ever possible to abandoned weight cutting?
Yes,
they should.
Healthier.
I'm sure I'd take a few years off my life every time I do it.
So I mean like when I cut in Florida,
I cut 18.8 in the last 20 hours.
Oh.
And I felt like at first you're hearing goes yeah.
And then your,
your vision goes and then you feel your body start to cramp up and you're like,
I'm fucking dying.
Literally.
Shit.
I'm literally,
this is how people die.
And then you have to put on a smile,
walk out and stare at the person.
Yeah.
Flex and stare at the person that you're going to fight tomorrow.
And then,
uh,
then you get to drink and take a couple of sips of PD,
like right after he stepped off the scale because you're literally dying.
I've seen some people that look like they're dying,
tried to in the NCAAs a few years ago for those that follow it,
they add,
you weighed in once and then you had the whole NCAA tournament,
you know,
so you went in once and then he wrestled for three days.
Uh,
then a kid at Michigan died cutting weight.
Yeah.
It was Kinda like tried to make it easier by having one weight cut and then they
could wrestle three days.
And then they realized that just encouraged people to cut more weight and a kid
from Michigan died and now you've got to weigh in every time.
And it's like when they make it harder,
you know,
it's like,
oh my God,
how can meet people weigh in and then fight?
Well,
it encourages people to cut less weight.
It's,
it's just you can't win.
When they tried to make it like you had a day in between guys just cut more
weight because they had a day to rehydrate.
It's cool.
I mean,
high school and high school coach is to treat you like you're a pussy if you
don't cut.
Oh,
putting on plastics and ugh.
And you're 14 which is a world
champion at 17 he was from Iraq,
from Iran.
Oh No.
[inaudible] 17 as was world champion and he,
he left the country so he,
he was,
you know,
an exile out here and wasn't able to wrestle in the Olympics and he would have
won gold.
Oh my God.
And he,
that's the person I was raised in wrestling by living in his house like two days
a week,
fucking screaming at me and Farsi,
Persian food is the best food for you.
Fuck you.
[inaudible]
every morning demanded things that I've never seen other people do.
Like he's just [inaudible] and the best person to me,
he'd be definitely saved my life.
That's awesome.
That's great man.
But as a,
as a Raza Bressler was a savage.
Those,
those guys,
man,
first of all,
wrestling in that part of the world is enormously important.
It's a hugely coveted Olympic sport.
Wrestling in Iran is gigantic.
When the iron was cousins for food,
like the is used to have whoever,
whoever won the kids one that they would buy the dinner or the,
yeah,
the Lizard by the dinner.
Jesus Christ.
He'd be in the sauna with me massaging me like a 16 year old kid cutting weight,
massaging me,
trying to meet,
get me to cut weight.
And He'd been looking at us at us and they were like,
what the fuck is this old man doing?
Does he have a little boy making him sweat in here?
I,
the thing about me in high school was smaller,
was the hundred and three pounds.
Wow.
Wait,
cluster one three,
three,
three is 12 and nineteens.
And what would you actually way before he started the cut,
I remember by senior year I was probably 35.
Uh,
I was supposed to cut weight in high school,
but I wouldn't do it.
So I walked around at 135 pounds on a Russell 134 pounds cause I was like,
I'm not doing it.
I just like you guys are dying.
I see it all around me.
There was a kid that was a one weight class above me,
this really big,
a really big tall kid.
I forget what his name is,
but he used to weigh like he would wrestle at one 40 something and he would
weigh 170 pounds and I just didn't understand that he was a big kid.
You know,
we were 15 at the time where he meet,
he might've been a little older,
maybe 16 but he was a big kid and I was watching this guy put on rubber suits
and run up hills and rolling around with covered in towels and shit.
And I was like hiding under the wrestling mats,
translating under the wrestling mat.
I'm not doing it.
And I cut weight a few times for Taekwondo tournaments.
And then I went up a weight class and fought,
I weighed one 54 [inaudible] 54 it was just,
for me,
it was way better.
I was just too lean anyway.
I was always walking around,
very low body fat.
So I just felt terrible.
The worst I ever saw was Marcos Galvan.
He fought chase,
BB and Beltre.
He could barely get on the scale.
He couldn't walk.
And then he got off the scale and he was going to the elevator and he sat down
and he started convulsing.
He started shaking.
And what people don't understand is next day against chase
BBI,
he looked great.
Phenomenal.
The amount they get back almost encourages that kind of shit when you go.
If they walked in there and just felt so bad,
they couldn't fight,
you'd,
you wouldn't see guys do it.
Well,
they wrote to cover some of that,
encourages them to do it.
You do
some guys that you,
you know,
they're taking,
they're hurting.
Like,
you know,
they get down to like a perfect example is a,
that dude who,
uh,
was uh,
Daniel Seraphim who is a killer at 185 pounds,
just fought at one 70.
And you can see for the moment he stepped into the octagon,
he was just,
he barely made weight and the moment he stepped in the octagon,
he just didn't do it.
I couldn't grab it.
It was just missing.
His timing was off.
His strength was off.
He just,
he just didn't have it.
Marquardt just decided to go back up to 85 beats to Huna last night.
What did he say?
God made him,
God made him do it.
God told him to fight at 105 yes.
Don't you questioning God.
Fuck no bro.
Slap on this triangle.
It looks like he's a little tighter with it now guys.
One angle their hips enough.
Nope.
I also don't know rubber guard.
I mean,
you know,
I know a lot of people are prejudice against Eddie Bravo techniques,
but that fucking mission control to triangle,
they don't know how to attack off their back with anything.
The rubber garden.
MMA is one of the best moves ever because you can hold a guy down with your arm,
you grab him and you're not just pulling down with your arm.
You point down with your legs as well and if you have a good triangle set up off
of that,
it's just a phenomenal move.
So many guys don't do it,
so you're left just trying to use your legs to pull the guy down or your reach
up and grab his neck.
He knows what you're doing.
If you get your hand that under hook on that ankle and you're pulling down on
that ankle with good flexibility at good rubber guard,
that mission control position is a devastating position.
But even coming from in,
in my case,
Carlson Gracie style,
which is,
which is a lot of open guard still like that,
like mural Bustamante hips are always moving.
They're just active the whole time.
When you believe in that or not,
no matter what your school is,
it's active hips and active fundamentals and,
and guys have surprising a little of that,
you know,
well Jeeva is my coach.
She was a stud.
People don't know.
Jake shields just came in and rolled and Jake always been had an open invitation
of the gym and he just shutting up one night.
I'm like,
oh,
what's up dude?
It's against shit role.
And then after OGV he's like,
why didn't you tell me that he was so good?
He was like,
I usually,
I usually come into gyms and I don't want to embarrass the coach.
So I really easy.
He's like,
holy cow,
I've never been swept.
Somebody's like,
he was like,
wow,
you know,
and Jared Wallins remember when he up war machine,
it's Jeeva.
Jeeva is a fuck man.
It's crazy how good he is.
All Butterfly Guard,
a butterfly guy does the everything.
I mean he said,
but not,
I wouldn't say rubber guard stuff.
Some of the guys were so good off.
Is Crazy.
So important.
I mean,
and it's,
it's basic,
you know,
on bark type Jujitsu with a lot of elbows,
pushing the head out,
hips out blasts and people,
you know,
like trying to create damage.
Who Do you think he's got the best garden and may right now
fibery show we're doing.
I mean the dude fucking finished fade or on my years it would have been
[inaudible] I think.
I think it's we're past that point.
Yeah.
It used to be in his prime and it's oral.
Heavyweight wise.
I don't Demian Maia has got a great one.
I don't,
I don't totally agree with that.
I think [inaudible] a pad and amazing guard,
but if you put,
I believe if you put from BC,
we're doing the same scenario,
he would tap those guys quicker.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't think anybody's better than off their back then Virginia.
He is outstanding.
He is really grave.
See,
he's insane.
The way he keeps his feet on the hips.
We keeps guys moving around.
You watched that fate or fight.
It's not just impressive the way he submitted him.
It's like the fight was over.
As soon as he was locked up in a skosh took it out of mid air.
It wasn't like he fell into it.
I mean,
Carl never could do that.
I mean minutes take a line.
He would take a ton of damage and it gets them and allows them to go,
is this really worth it?
You are getting the years beaten out of you,
man.
But he didn't,
he couldn't pull it off in his prime on fader.
Granted,
fader was in his prime in that fight and he wasn't in his prime.
In the boardroom fight.
Yeah,
but still for doing them.
I think I just went just amazing during it.
I think he's the best.
You know who's really good at,
you know,
it doesn't get a lot of credit for,
is that Charles Alovera kid?
Yeah.
It's wicked off his battery.
Good Guard.
Wicked standing up to men.
That fight with Frankie.
Edgar was fucking awesome.
Yeah.
He fought last night,
right.
Didn't know.
I didn't see it last.
He fought.
He fought in a,
on that to Hoonah card.
Ellenberger wins a decision.
Haufle Ellenberger good for him,
man.
Good for him.
Let's hope that eyes,
I know,
man.
I hope he didn't.
Yeah,
he fought last night.
I'm
trying to find the fight card here.
Is the ufc.com not the best fucking website in the world.
Uh,
he fought hot Sukiyaki and he beat hot Sukiyaki decision or I don't know.
I haven't seen it yet.
We could watch that later.
Shinya Yogi for a lot of years,
I think had the best one of the best guards in MMA.
Oh fuck.
Oh my God.
What do you think about the tights like that?
That was like the big thing that he wore tights in pride,
which are great for traction.
Yeah.
But they wouldn't let him wear it when he fought anywhere else.
I don't really understand that.
He stopped too key.
It was the first time hot.
So he oak,
he got stopped and by the way,
hey,
Yo key just a couple of years ago was thought of as the number one guy had 145
pounds and uh,
has not done so he got an arm and guillotine.
He got them with an army gating.
The way he cinched it up,
it looks like a lucky,
wrapped it up Dar style.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Not that long.
No ma'am.
All three of us in this room got a little stubby.
Fuck.
Silly monkey arms.
Yeah.
I envy guys like Tony Ferguson,
those long ass arms.
They,
Tony Darcy's from everywhere.
Bill Cooper Jujitsu.
Oh yeah,
lock you up.
You're done.
[inaudible] Gracie.
None.
That's you acceptable.
Those long arm dudes man.
They just really know how to get those certain submissions.
That was the worst spinning back by not good.
Not good at all.
Fitting bat buck kick.
But a props to that dude for a taking that fight on short notice like last
minute.
I think a little prep.
You might have one.
That one.
It's a good fight too.
It was a fun fight.
Close ass kicked for the first five minutes.
Fucking I looked pretty bad man.
That I looked real bad.
So let's see what else we got here.
What is next?
This fucking fight card.
I'm so excited about this main event.
I know it's real close to your buddy and I know it's hard for you,
but I'm excited about this.
I just sometimes I just don't want to see my friends get beat up course.
Right.
It makes it understandable.
I don't mind getting beat up myself.
Yeah,
I'd rather not.
It's,
uh,
a lot of guys say that it's harder when you walk in your teammates up then that
is when you're walking yourself up.
Do you feel like that completely.
Yeah,
cause I,
I just want to go,
I know what I'm doing,
you know,
I can control what's going on and usually it ends up pretty well.
So I just,
uh,
I like it.
But whether the people,
it's like sometimes you're thinking you suck at this,
you suck at that,
don't do that.
Don't look at me and smile and get thrown.
Like that's the worst
I have heard in my career some really horrible coaching.
Oh man,
that stands out to me.
I think more than anything when you're,
when you're commentating in like in between rounds,
man,
I know we pay per view and on TV is very different depending on what you do,
whether or not we see the routes,
see the,
see the coaches in between rounds is up to the producer and all this stuff.
So it's a lot of times where I'm sitting there watching the coach and you know,
play by play guys doing something and I'm like,
that is the worst advice I have ever heard of.
Like,
like,
like they don't know what they're talking about.
I liked the,
it'll say the awful,
you will say that though.
You will say,
well I'm out man.
Yeah I will.
I'll call it like they're pissing me later to add sometimes I've got a couple
people mad at me but I like that it's just a word or you're winning this fight
and I'm like,
what fight are you looking at?
You are down four rounds to none.
That's never good to lie to you.
Fighter cheerleading.
Some guy he cheerleading the McCoy's still.
Some guys are really,
you know,
I think he's the best.
Matt Hume.
Very good.
He's so specific.
So specific about what's going on and what,
what you're doing wrong or what you could do to make that a little bit better.
Very technical.
And then you'll hear other guys where it's like it's you all day long.
Put your punches together.
Like they say a bunch of shit pushed the pace.
Like what do you say?
You're not saying anything.
The worst one,
the worst I remember distinctly was Bj Penn's corner saying go at him.
Oh,
for an over,
I think it was actually the Jens Pulver finds his way back for the old fans and
they're going go him Hilo style like 20 times.
And I went that you're not saying anything.
It was low style,
but it was like his tenement had always gotten that far.
So when it didn't work,
they didn't know what to do.
It's like we never coached him before.
Why are we going to start now?
It's soup.
It was just,
I remember laughing mammals too.
Right.
When you have that dynamic of one guy,
the Alpha,
the Super Alpha,
have you been here Jay?
No,
I've been to Hilo,
but I've never been to Bj's camp.
I stayed just stayed at his parents' house.
What does it like?
It's so much fun.
I would move there if I could.
I love that.
Beautiful.
So beautiful.
And it's like a,
it's like the tech,
the little town.
My girlfriend was,
you know,
raised in,
uh,
like Mindin Nevada Garnerville like right below Tahoe.
But it's that Shonda by jungle.
It's a tiny little town and everyone's cool and you just sit around and go to
the beach.
But there's a lot of fights.
So isn't there a lot of fist fights?
Awesome.
Should be getting into fistfights.
You'd tell your daughter that.
Well,
no shit that girls shouldn't ever site.
That's disgusting.
But tell say Rudy,
you know about [inaudible] UFC belt this weekend,
you might get a fucking text message.
DFW,
understanding how much shit talking again,
I fuck with everybody.
It's Twitter.
Simmer down and then you get people saying some nerdy shit like we're Mcdonald's
sent me the wiki links to two like idiot or something.
I was like,
oh,
that's a real good comeback.
What did you do?
Because you said he had never gotten in a fist fight that the USC is creating
pussies that I've never been at this one.
We have the best.
Awesome.
We have the world's best athletes and like Demetrius,
I doubt he's ever even been in a fist fight in his life,
but he beat my ass.
You know,
he,
that second fight,
he beat me up.
So I'm just saying that a lot of guys,
they just aren't scary.
Like I comment to go from not scary to pussy is a pretty big league mean.
He's not an animal.
You mean like if some shit goes down on the street he wants to beat the shit out
of you and then liquids,
gloves and you know,
chuck wants to beat the shit out of you and you know,
bone your chick.
I just kidding.
I'm just back in the day.
But that's who I was raised by,
you know,
so I have a different outlook on it is this fucking savages and the guys that
are just there to be athletic.
One of the biggest transitions,
I'm a deck,
I'm sorry.
No,
one of the biggest transitions in mmm,
well the last 10 years has been,
it used to be a sport of martial arts and fighters.
Now the support of athletes and I go,
these guys are at there just stud athletes who kind of went in that direction.
They didn't grow up going,
you know,
watching bloodsport and wanting to be that guy or you know,
getting in fist fights and going,
gee,
I'm going to go to jail phone,
do this for money.
That breed.
Those two halves are kind of gone now.
It's like these crazy good athletes that kind of grew up.
Yeah.
I was a cross country runner and I was football player and I wanted to MMA.
So the,
I get what you're saying in the terms of it,
it's become more of a sport of athletes.
Have guys with dude just have athletic backgrounds,
like never really improved guys who are really good at other sports.
Who like Matt Mitrione.
Yeah,
really good
at for freaky ass.
I just having to say things in a really rude manner as all I gotcha.
Well you make a point though.
I see what you're saying and translate.
I'm a translator and what he means is stupid and he just goes,
I get my job.
Part of my job I'm Clint has brought to fight.
Now he's fighting a Antonio Braga Braga and Neto.
And um,
Hester who fights at one 85.
They were just saying on the underground how we uh,
he weighed in today at two oh five.
Yeah,
he's strict.
He's a big fella and he's a good athlete too.
That's a strong cat.
Hard,
hard striker and a Neto.
Who is a,
he's fought in the UFC before.
Um,
I think he's nine and one,
I think he's fought in the UFC and we look at his,
um,
cause I know there's some guys that are making their debuts.
Machito was into that glory fight,
man.
It's just a commercial and a sheet on it.
I need them.
Machita said that he was interested in fighting art 11.
It's
crazy.
I trained with at Don's and he's probably the best 15 pounder.
You know,
this country's ever seen two and 12 pounder.
And when he turns,
when he turns it up,
Oh my God,
it is so scary.
I mean he's the only guy that they bring ties over and you know,
knock some,
most of them out.
Now.
He's,
he,
you know,
he's 112 pound fighter and he hits like,
like a heavyweight.
It's,
it's,
it,
it's fucking crazy.
He's the only person I'm afraid of where I'm like,
oh my God,
you're going to fucking put me out at any point.
And that's,
that's high level.
Kickbox and that's world class kickboxing.
I used to drink with a mallet pet over it.
You know how scary it is,
dude?
Holy Jesus.
It was like you got shot by a gun.
It was,
it was,
yeah,
we were,
I was getting a guy named Kenny Johnson who just cornered actually,
uh,
a wrestler.
I was cornering him for a fight out in orange county somewhere and mallow pet
was fighting wild man.
Danny in the main event and King of the cage.
Yeah.
Something like that.
And we're,
you know,
they're two separate rooms and in the room next to us,
it sounded like someone was shooting a rifle off.
Like literally I got up and I turned and was mallet hitting pads.
Yeah.
It was ridiculous.
You get hit you,
it's horrible.
Yeah.
You got guns and Yeltsin,
Cli,
Cli fair techs.
Our techs,
we're afraid text Jim affiliate.
Yeah.
And it's just,
Oh my God.
Or the guy that just,
he hit Romy was an elbow like five seconds in just,
and then all of a sudden started smiling and pointing and then Romy was like
fucking turn around and just had this giant vagina in the front of his head.
And it was,
I saw a fight.
It was fucking scary.
Yeah,
he's nasty.
He's nasty.
Like super bond.
And those little tie guys,
I mean they're,
they're like,
they want us to go out there and I'm like,
I don't fucking,
then those guys hardly ever spar.
They don't talk.
They feel safe.
They fail 300 times by the time they're 25 which is just absolutely incredible.
If you've ever been a ton.
And it's really weird when they have a five round fight,
they don't fight in the first round because they're feeling each other out.
They kill each other rounds two,
three and four and they don't fight in the fifth round.
They carry each other.
And I asked my coaches time,
I was training Tamika,
why did they do it?
And he goes,
you fight next week.
There's no point.
We already know who won basically on the cards,
so why would you destroy your body?
You got to fight and like a week.
Why?
They just don't give us just a little a fifth round.
It's like,
all right,
I know you once.
Let's just,
and a lot of rambling stuff,
lot of gambling.
That is so interesting that they do that.
Do you think that tie,
um,
decisions are better?
They're better at making decisions because that's the big issue in MMA.
It's like don't leave it in the hands of the judges,
which I hate to,
I hate that expression.
Yeah.
We have a,
we have one of my least favorite Shitty,
you know,
judging system.
Yeah,
we need to change,
but how are we going to change it and fuck,
I don't,
right.
There's so many options and the people have so many ideas and they all seem
okay,
but there's always holes in them and yeah,
you get bad decisions in boxing that's been around for a hundred years and you
have 12 rounds and you get horrible decisions.
Remember that one woman out there was one woman who was a boxing judge who uh,
she judged a Bradley.
We let the over pack.
Yeah,
I remember she also called the main,
whether it hurts another one.
May what the Mayweather,
uh,
the Mayweather fight,
she called it a draw me.
Hello?
Hello.
Yeah.
And everybody was like,
what the fuck was so bad that they brought in the Nevada state governor?
They kicked her out.
Yeah.
They kicked her out and they brought in the divided state governor.
And the,
the real concern amongst people in the know was that she might be getting paid
off by gamblers.
That a gambler who,
who wanted to ensure,
like if you've got a fight where you know,
a guy who's going to win by decision like Floyd Mayweather vs Canelo,
you could safely bet a lot of money knowing the flow.
I mean,
shit can happen.
Yeah.
Canelo can win,
but most likely you're going to see Floyd boxes face off most likely.
And that is what happened.
But she didn't see it that way.
And she makes it a draw and then it's not a majority to sit or now it's on
unanimous decision.
You could bet against it not being in a unanimous decision.
Yeah.
Big Vegas Elbow.
And so,
uh,
okay.
Braga versus Hester and Braga does have one fight in the,
or Neto rather.
He does have one fight in the UFC and he's got a,
he's got a victory.
He fought on the under card.
Yeah.
I've seen Hester fight.
And this is his style,
that athletic hands down kind of explosive style,
but it's getting caught by the left a lot.
Mr It's a BC that they do not look like they're in the same weight class.
Yeah.
He's enormous.
That's cut.
And that,
wait baby cutting that,
wait.
It works.
I like seeing are that our new bantamweight champions,
uh,
doesn't cut much weight.
It doesn't seem like he does.
No,
I don't think he cuts wants weight at all.
Tj.
Uh,
I think at the most,
a couple of pounds.
Yeah.
He's a beast.
And that's a perfect example of finding the right teacher and the right pupil.
Yeah,
him and Dwayne just fucking gel together.
And Dwayne is a,
just a total madman.
So Neto is a,
he's a world champion,
uh,
under,
under Gordo.
Is this,
does it evolve?
MMA in Brazil evolves,
uh,
the,
the rich guys.
Jim,
I do not know.
And then that's the one in Singapore I think.
Let's see.
I've treated the all in Singapore
when we were out.
Yeah,
you're right.
Chattery dancing classes.
You'll dogs sit the Diane,
I loved it.
All these rich rich dudes are doing that.
Like these crazy guys like Dan Lambert from American top team and the guy that
did it over it,
a black zillions.
I loved these guys are doing that and they're the same thing.
He would Texas to teen takedown.
Yeah.
You know all of the wrestlers.
Those motherfuckers,
they,
those guys get paid.
They get like a salary.
You get these rich dudes that nice fine animals like Johnny Hendricks.
They find these fucking animals.
Give them a world class facility,
hire world class coaches,
guys like mark layman to go out there and teach them Jujitsu.
Great striking coaches and wrestling coaches and just build world champions.
Man,
they have a weird deal too,
like the word,
like they give up like 50% of their purse to the gym.
Like the gym pays for everything,
gives them a salary,
takes care of everything.
But then they get a,
the gym gets a big cut of their,
they're winning.
Now I want to bring up something that we're in the right,
well we have the right peoples slick this guy and he's putting pressure on,
it's not letting him up.
Yeah.
That,
that system,
that situation.
There's a fighter that will remain nameless and we were like,
he had kind of plateaued and we said,
you know,
you should,
you should move on.
I don't think your Jim's doing it right for you.
You know,
like,
I'm just as a friend and he went,
they're paying me a salary.
I really can't leave.
Like,
Ooh.
He was like,
I can't afford to walk away.
They're paying me too much to leave and find the right gym.
And it was interesting.
I was like,
yeah man.
That system where it's,
you know,
if,
if you're not fighting for your purse and a guy's paying you a salary,
but you're not getting the train you need,
could he keep you somewhere?
That's the,
I think maybe the downside of that kind of system,
you're kind of tied to it.
Yeah.
That could be the downside to that system if the guy's not fully committed to,
to his athletes.
Now,
I mean,
I think that's an all in sort of a proposition.
If you're going to start that kind of a big gym,
you gotta,
you gotta be fully committed to your,
it's your athletes
and you're going to pay for whatever they want,
whatever coach they want.
If it's someone's not good enough,
I'm going to say it.
Yeah.
If I'm beating up one of my coaches,
I'm going to be like,
ah,
I'm good.
I wonder what happened with Kenny Monday.
You know,
cause he,
when he left the black Zillions,
yeah.
I mean you can't get a better wrestling coach in that guy there.
They fired him.
Well this fight,
this is the kind of pressure we were talking about,
Joe,
that you don't see a whole lot in MMA.
He's got really good positioning,
really good pressure.
He looked to the referee.
That's,
that's shit is getting annoying.
That looking through the referee to come meet him.
He's out.
That's my favorite.
Yeah,
the guys and the good.
And you're saying he's out and they stopped the fight and he's awake.
That's off.
Do you remember that Yoshida Hoists Gracie fight where he pretended that hoist
was out?
Yup.
And Noyce was fine.
Mack Danzig versus uh,
who got him into QT.
Matt Wyman and cities.
That's right.
Yup.
He wasn't out at all.
I mean,
yeah,
but that's
easy to tell though.
A graph or that's easy to tell if a guy's out.
That's unexcusable.
That's an uneducated judge.
Kaye o's are weird like earlier today.
Um,
oh no.
On the old,
a nice arm trap.
I love seeing good Jujitsu and MMA.
I really do.
Johnny Bedford,
pretty heavy.
Heavy hips,
man.
Johnny Bedford got fucked over earlier today for that.
He got nailed with a punch.
Went down and you know he got rocked.
It got,
but the referee stopped the fight and immediately and you know he got up like
what the fuck?
Screaming and yelling.
This is bullshit.
Clearly not wobbly.
Told him,
yeah,
don't touch him,
don't us.
Don't push.
We're talking.
The reason why we're saying that is fucking Jason High Man,
Baby Push.
It was nothing freaking out that the fight got stopped.
He freaks out in the moment.
Touches the referee,
banned for life from the UFC and suspended for a year,
which I disagree with it.
I think the referee,
that's one thing you think of Ronda Rousey pushed the referee.
They would have that same reaction as what are the risks?
What if Rhonda Rousey lost?
Okay,
what if,
let's say some crazy shit happened.
Some Liz Carmouche style.
Remember when Liz had run his back would,
if someone sinks that in and really fucking locks it up and clamps it down and
Rhonda goes out or rotted taps or the referee thinks that Ron has got a tap and
the referee stopped the fight and then Ronnie fucking freaks out and pushes the
referee,
what would happen?
Would it be the same because it's a woman doing it?
Would it be,
I mean,
Jason,
I didn't hurt anybody.
You know,
it has nothing to do with being a woman.
And then I see the point of zero tolerance.
Don't push.
Don't touch the restroom.
I don't.
I totally do too,
but I totally get your point as to if Rhonda did that,
would they have the same reaction?
Find Him.
Find him $1,000.
Okay,
that sounds right to me.
I think it's,
they took 19 hundreds and a year.
They took 10% well,
the 10% is a good amount.
That's good.
Don't do that.
Don't touch the referee now.
You know the referee fucked up.
Yes,
but it was pretty God damn clothes.
You got hurt.
He got hurt pretty bad.
Don't touch the referee,
but God damn it.
You don't,
I don't,
I just,
I think Jason has a good guy.
I've known him,
you know,
I've,
I've talked to him,
I think he's a good guy.
I liked the way he fights.
He's a good fighter.
It sucks to me to see a guy like that get banned.
But,
but I see it on from their point of view.
You,
you know,
you've got to set a zero tolerance policy to any shenanigans.
That's why,
I mean,
look at Semtex Paul Daley.
So fucking bad.
Motherfucker like one of the best at one 71 of the most exciting guys to watch,
that's for sure.
Took a fucking sucker punch at Josh Koscheck and he's been gone ever since.
And Dag Dan [inaudible] on a sucker.
If I hit him up like a toy dude,
I'll never forget that night.
Like principal,
you'd pick up a dog that bit you like a pug and what?
God Damn it and like shook him.
Know that.
Oh my God.
Has it been big giant man,
big boy and a very nice guy too.
He's a great,
like Dan [inaudible].
He used to get a a hard time from a lot of people because he was one of the
original referees for elite Xc and elite Xc had some dog shit rules.
They were trying to stand people up after 15 seconds like Jake shields cut
Semtex and elite ECC with an arm bar and it was like he was,
he was running to get that arm bar before they stood him up.
If you were a grappler in elite x,
Z,
boy,
you were at a fucking bad place.
You were in a big country,
had Andre Arlovski on the ground inside control,
double wrist lock working the Komora and they stand them up and you're like,
why?
I remember that.
I can side control the Camorra.
Stand them up,
stand them up.
That fat fuck.
Who was that fucking guy?
That promoter?
That's sloppy Jello face.
Motherfucker.
Don't even say his name and he's like,
fucking,
he's Candyman.
He'll show up.
Oh that fucking gross person.
Those guys ruined MMA for a while and they got on show the gun on CBS with that
Shit.
It's amazing how far they got with it.
When you think about it so far as idiots so far.
Meanwhile,
we're watching an awesome fight.
Soaps coming back in the second row there in the second round and Braga extended
a lot of energy trying to get Hester to the ground and try to submit them,
but couldn't submit him.
And now Hester stuffs that takedown.
Super easy.
Okay.
It's a big athletic person.
Yeah man.
Look,
look at this as to take him down.
Beautiful.
I don't,
we'll see how it's not.
It seems like probably a bad idea.
Look at that deep half both legs locked up.
That's sweet.
That's a beautiful nice.
Oh my God.
I love that.
Both legs locked up in the deep half.
You're in fucking trouble,
man.
You've got to explode to get out of that.
Is this nettle full mountain now?
That was gorgeous.
I love seeing shit like that.
I really do.
I don't see enough of it.
You don't mean you got like jock array.
Damien Maia,
this guy.
You've got like a few worldclass guys.
If y'all know Fernandez one the best for sure.
Okay.
Few worldclass guys,
but man,
it has to.
It has got to be bummed out.
He now he's all gift wrapped.
That's a sucky spot and he's doing that thing where you stick your thumb inside
the glove.
Ooh,
right in front of everybody.
I know.
We can see you right.
He was barely doing it though.
His defense.
But you can use your own gloves.
You know who uses his own God?
Josh Thomson does that real well.
He'll get like a rear naked or a gay teen and get his hands deep in his own
glove.
That's nice.
That's a nice grip and I let,
I guess you're at least,
you used to be allowed to do that with your gloves,
but you can't do it with your opponents gloves.
Just sort of like you can grab your shorts,
can't grab the other guy shorts to protect you like a Kamora like ims Cotita.
He did that for like 20 minutes
for the old school fence.
Old School son.
I was there for the original guy,
Metzger Tito fight.
We're guy Metsker getting fucked up in Hamilton and they checked him for cuts.
They go back in Toledo shoots and guy caught him in a good team.
I had a fight last season where a guy had his,
was back mounted through a headbutt backwards.
I saw that point and they stood him up.
Ridiculous.
I went,
what the fuck is this?
Ridiculous?
And I was so glad that you did.
I would have been a dude.
Stick it out of that.
I'll take a point away.
This is Renee.
Good show.
I'm so happy.
I was furious that you do commentary like that.
Do you call guys out on that and you don't just let that shit go.
I love that you do that.
I can't wait.
Of course you can't look at this.
Meanwhile,
Neto on top in half guard,
Joe Rigs,
Matt Hughes in Half Guard.
You can get this.
Uh,
he let it go though.
Decided look,
oh,
that was him.
The route,
because he knows how much to commit to it and a lot of guys don't because you
don't come off from half courts.
Tough.
It's tough.
Especially the guys got a good half guard.
Unless you like knowing where to put a character in one of those big country
strong motherfuckers.
You know,
Matt Hughes could just Yank that shit off your body,
but it's also the hip thing.
You have to have know how high you have to be up with your hips and lot of guys
just don't know.
I know.
Yup.
Yeah.
It's interesting that the level of Jujitsu,
but it's also interesting level striking and MMA.
The problem within the May is that there's so much to learn.
If you're an athlete and you're getting into MMA,
see like a lot of these guys,
like maybe in your thirties and the MMA,
God damn,
there's a learning curve.
There's so much to learn.
There's so much to this sport that you're seeing sort of like you don't see
class anything in most fighters.
You see they're really good at a couple of things.
But when you see a guy who's worldclass like as like an ardent,
if art and 11 started fighting in MMA,
right?
The big thing would be talking about this guy striking for sure because he's
world class as a kickboxer.
And if you'd compare his striking to most guys in MMA,
you know,
outside of the guys who really stand out,
you go,
well that's just some,
that's that's what it really should look like.
Yeah.
But for every fighter of a particular discipline that goes into MMA with a ton
of credentials,
who you got as a blue chip,
this guy's got to do well,
I can point out somebody who,
same thing tanked.
That's true.
You just can't tell anymore where Intel,
where guys come in with a background in something you think,
man,
this guy's got to be a beast and it just doesn't work out.
You know,
I hear they all third round Hester probably down two rounds if you,
uh,
we barely,
I mean we really shouldn't be scoring in here cause we're not really paying
attention.
Oh Nice.
Straight ones.
Hester is going after him here.
Big Shot to the body
and Neto got tagged.
Oh officers tagging him.
Oh my God,
he's
so crazy.
He was fucking him up chest.
We were talking about and you're athletic,
you're physical,
powerful,
but don't have your feet under you.
It's not going to help you.
Yeah.
And all he's doing on the bottom is surviving.
I mean,
he's not getting up to his feet.
He's not escaping.
He's not,
I mean,
he got him down once with that beautiful hip toss,
but then what happened?
You got slapped half swept.
That's a beautiful deep half sweep to,
I want to see that more often.
It's probably pretty tough to get both legs trapped in there like that.
It's one of those weird situations like,
uh,
when uh,
Benevidez fought Tim Elliot and had both his arms trap in the Guillotine,
so he had a tablet.
It's feet.
It was crazy.
He goes,
look,
it's beautiful.
Transition to the Mount Neto is just so slick
at Saks when someone does that to you.
Yeah.
I've never seen that,
that sort of,
uh,
that position where it guys,
both arms are trapped and he's getting guillotined
now's got sick mountain.
It happens.
It can happen a lot when guys go underneath both ways for the past,
especially with the [inaudible] that choke over the,
the front kron Gracie does it all the time.
Yeah,
it's a pain.
The key is a whole new world.
Jeff Glover likes that too.
He'll sit back when you try and pass on eighth his legs,
he'll sit back and give it to you.
I'll hop right over your back.
But that's his thing.
You don't see it a lot in a moment.
He's a master.
He really is.
Glover is a master and kids would be so good at Jujitsu.
He,
you know,
he's doing something that Mitch Clark just started doing that.
Uh,
he'll like let you pass into a Darce.
Glover was like one of the first guys I ever saw do that.
And now Mitch Clark was the first guy to ever pull that off in the UFC on ally
Quinta.
Yeah.
Beautiful submission.
Like let go to let and he's passing as he's passing.
He thinks he's getting signed.
Controlled falls right into a locked up.
Doris,
you gotta have a lot of confidence in your darts to pull that off though.
Yeah.
It's gotta be strong.
You've got to have wrong,
like good.
You got to know that that Shit's money.
Well,
Ooh,
Clint tagged him.
Hester had him really badly hurt at the beginning of this round man and now he's
on top in the guard.
He might be able to finish this fight if he could tag this to it a few times
when he doesn't seem like he would,
that kind of frame.
He hasn't gassed.
Yeah.
Well he's,
he's real cognizant about pacing himself.
You know,
he actually talked about it recently that there was a time where he was fighting
and he was tagging the guy and I was saying he probably be best served to back
off right now and not gas out because if a guy is still there and you unload on
him.
And so he backed off and then he thanked me after the fight.
I was like,
that was good advice,
man.
Uh,
he,
he's on top and he's fucking Neto up.
Oh,
big elbow.
Dave Jansen,
Kia Tina guy.
One time.
It didn't one,
cause I told him too.
I didn't tell him too.
I just said it's a good position for a beauty.
He goes,
I heard you went for the kitchen and you got it.
Yeah,
you're welcome.
It's a weird thing like sometimes guys will be right in front of me and I'll say
what he's got to do to pass this when he's got to do to get out and you'll see
the guy doing it.
But you know you're kind of coaching them but you kind of have to it just
because they're in front of you.
You still have to say stop talking.
Yeah.
You still have to say what's your should be done.
Next time I pick somebody up,
I'm going to throw him over right there.
Tell me what to do.
I'll help you out if I know and sometimes I'm baffled.
What do you think about having big crazy dreadlocks like that?
That would make it harder to get out of shit?
Wouldn't a lot harder I imagine.
I mean it looks sexy as fuck Clint,
but God damn son,
you also blind to dude,
if you send your guard and moving his head around the whole time.
Well,
I always thought that about clay.
Seriously.
Clay,
Cancun.
See Shit,
the Predator going on.
I mean [inaudible] has got the craziest hair ever.
Yeah.
Fighting with that hair.
And the other thing is what if you get hit,
it goes flying through the air.
It,
it makes it look little.
You got to hit a lot harder than you did.
I've been,
Hennessy is always fucking with his hair.
Every time he fights it look good man.
How about the fact that the dude used to fight with a toothpick in his mouth?
It's ridiculous.
Fought championship level fights with the fucking toothpick in his mouth.
Is he going to have to take them down to the officially catch that or he'd just
stopped it.
I caught it.
I know they,
they caught him.
Did they go cut that shit out?
Check his mouth.
Okay,
good.
Yeah,
they like alerted him and no one certain terms like bro,
he can't do that.
He's so crazy,
guys fighting world champions.
He's got a fucking toothpick in his mouth.
I don't know where he was sticking that thing on this tooth as his mouthpiece,
but it's a lower,
he's hiding in the lower part of his mouth and your throat.
You're done in the middle of a fight.
It could too.
Oh easily going to get rocked.
Everybody gets rocked.
You gotta look smooth and you know,
I mean,
so arguably that was in his face in his mouth when he got showtime kicked when
Anthony Pennys yeah,
leaping kicked him in the face and he went flying.
He had a toothpick in his mouth
I think.
I mean,
I don't worry.
I swallowed it.
I know he did once Matt.
And the reason why I know he did is because the fight was over.
I was watching him and then all sudden I watched him pull a toothpick out of his
mouth.
Like I saw the fight being over the is fine I believe.
Cause that's,
remember you talking about it?
I believe it was the Diaz fight.
I don't,
I'm not sure though,
but whatever it was,
he had a toothpick in his mouth and I go,
where'd you get that too?
I like,
I asked him in the post fight interview like,
where'd you get that toothpick?
Like you had to pick any my like,
no,
no.
And then I talked to John Crouch about and he's like,
yeah,
I can't get them to stop doing that.
Like you can't get him to stop fighting with a bucket
of all the shit you can get him to do in training.
You can't go.
Don't do this life threatening shit.
You gotta pick your battles.
Oh,
great shape.
He doesn't drink,
doesn't parties and athlete.
He's smart.
He does everything right.
You know,
but it comes to that.
Nope,
I'm going to fight with tooth.
Pick up my mouth.
Oh God,
look at
champ.
Forgot the bell.
I guess you can do that.
Yeah.
Fuck man.
How good is God?
Damn Anthony Pettis.
Yeah.
Fuck that guy's good.
He gives this stud.
Awesome.
His kicking is.
He do grief is is on the podcast last week and we showed me,
he showed me a kickboxing bout or an MMA bout where he got taken down.
He got slammed,
his shoulder popped out of place.
My shoulder was fucked up.
He got stood back up.
You could see his shoulder was fucked.
He's moving away from the guy.
Boom lands a high kick,
knocked the guy out with a fucked up shoulder.
I was like hanging off of his body and he landed a beautiful picture.
Perfect wrap around left high kick just like you landed on Lozan.
What I don't want to see honestly what concerns me is,
is
Gotcha Ring Russ
being a huge factor in his career.
Yeah.
Injuries.
Just keep him out so much.
I just,
I hate seeing guys like that are so talented,
but no,
I don't want to say fragile,
but injury prone.
Have you want to put it where they don't get that rhythm they need,
I call myself clean Hester.
Got It.
Man.
Clint has to one interested in.
Very interesting.
I don't think I agree with that,
but yeah.
Well,
the neither does Neto.
It looks pretty upset,
but he took,
the first two would look like the third round he won.
I mean for sure.
Beaten them up in the third round in the beginning.
Took him to the ground.
He got mounted,
but then he got on top.
Wound up in his guard.
Yeah.
I thought I thought no one the first two rounds,
but I guess not.
Yeah.
Well who knows?
Who knows what the fuck the judges are saying?
That was a beautiful take down,
but show the deep half bit beautiful sweep.
Show the sweep.
It's funny how after fights they're only showing like the guy who wants island
look like a blowout.
I had to talk to my editor,
the the people who cut them.
I don't know if you have any input in that.
I,
I'll go to the truck and go,
guys,
you make it look like a blowout.
Like you give me a close fight and the replays are one dude beaten the other
dude.
I go,
you'd make it look like stop doing that.
The problem with that you have as they're doing this move of the fight thing,
so they're not calling it like a replay.
The calling,
the move of the fight,
but the fight,
that fight especially,
that was a very close fight.
Yeah,
it was a good fight.
So you got to show both sides and when you have something as beautiful is that
that sweep Charlotte Shit.
Michael Pena in the building.
He's an actor on end of watch.
Do you know what end of watches?
Yeah,
the movie into watch Jake Gyllenhaal.
Yeah.
Jake Gyllenhaal.
Yeah,
pin.
And he's funny in everything he does is it's a cop movie,
but like a serious cop movie where they know it was on a training day,
like a training day time.
Pretty recent,
right?
Yeah.
Pretty recent.
Couple of years.
You know what's going on,
their partners and someone dies or they both die or no gay cowboy stuff.
No.
Whenever I see Jake Eula Hall,
that's where your brain goes.
Oh,
that's where it goes.
No,
he said,
you suck one day here,
a cock sucker for the rest of your life.
I don't think you dad's the only guy says that you can build this.
You can build a million pills in your lifetime and never be a bridge builder.
Life life lessons.
Yeah.
There's some certain things you want to avoid and gay cowboy movies are one of
them,
but that's a funny one.
Covered pretty well man.
I both guys were,
the other ones were making fun of,
so I got to make,
he's doing all right.
Well I wouldn't take a tricked into it and my friends like,
hey,
you want to go see a movie about gay cowboys?
And this is when I was on drugs and I was back.
Nice.
Yeah,
that sounds hilarious.
That sounds so funny.
We got there and I'm like,
what the fuck you were looking for like a will Ferrell movie or some shit movie
about gay cowboy.
So I watched the whole thing.
It was great.
I enjoyed that movie tremendously.
All the wrong reasons as people made it happen.
It
was a comedy to me.
I don't know what everybody else saw spitting on his hand.
He shoved his dick and with one stroke like what you told me what's going on
here?
You could take the bit I want to I if it was just going to this you to answer
this question for me cause I want to put like Asca gay dude at some point.
Okay.
Seriously.
And this is,
this is an all serious and they're gonna lie to you.
So I know they lied to me but having sex with a chick you just met can be a
little longer.
You don't want,
she likes to know when you like you know can be a little awkward.
A dude,
we've got to go.
So are you,
am I,
are you because I don't are you like [inaudible] decision in like in a club in
15 seconds?
I'm just curious.
Like it's awkward numb that says yeah,
do they fuck every 15 seconds
but to go like so are you are cause I don't are you are cause was in the movie
they decided pretty quick.
I have friends.
Yeah.
You got to ask one and just go.
It's pretty obvious when you look at it if you don't know them.
If like if you just met them and just like,
like we have all taken the chicken,
the we didn't know and just went,
oh well,
but if you decide at some point,
yeah,
I think that they know.
You just know one guy,
he's the wife and one guy's the husbands instantly,
you know,
soon as you hit on them,
that's where they know up front some questions just about how he just,
he just got a brave
I imagine.
Breathe,
breathe.
Okay.
Everybody says about everything.
Very soundly.
Chamber breathe.
Just breathe.
The cryo chamber is supposed to be a mother fucker.
I got to do that in between rounds.
Breathe every day.
Wow.
How far away is it from your house?
It's in between my strength conditioning,
champagne,
my real gym.
Do you do a post workout or pre?
Um,
I do it at 10 o'clock every day.
So sometimes I work out before it and sometimes I don't work.
I just go straight there.
Is there any restrictions on,
for folks who don't know what the crowd chamber is explained with Nora's better
than me,
so I just do it everyday.
But yeah,
it's a,
you get into a little pod cylinder thing.
It opens up,
you get in,
they raise the floor up.
So your head's above the,
the top.
They pumping liquid nitrogen,
liquid nitrogen hits oxygen,
it turns into a gas science class.
And then,
uh,
it,
it's,
but it's heavier so it sits in there and it gets down to minus two 56 usually
Fahrenheit.
At W I set the record of our place for two 63.
Oh my God.
You wanted more,
you wanted it colder.
She just,
she just does it.
What's between you and she's like,
you can take it.
I'm going to try something and I'm like,
well I'm going to try something on you.
Yeah.
See degrees below zero isn't quite doing it.
So where I recommend that for everybody,
it's probably the singular best thing I've ever done.
Wow.
What way?
Recovery?
Recovery.
At least what it like what,
what does it do that so awesome.
Like give me just feel better and things like the swelling goes down of
everything.
Bruising goes away.
You get out and you only ended in the front for three minutes.
I mean I last three minutes,
but most people less than a minute two.
Wow.
I just [inaudible] he just got it out.
Yeah.
Just cause there's something wrong and then once you get you,
it's definitely something wrong with it.
And then once he get out,
it's just like all the blood flushes to your skin of rush of blood.
And I want to go,
you know,
this is a new thing too,
right?
They've only been doing it for the last one in Europe,
that gators decades.
Oh really?
Everything's been in Europe for instance,
as long as the u s has had for five years or something like that.
I don't know.
I mean it's,
it's pretty,
it's pretty awesome.
I think that,
uh,
people and let me know,
I took my daughter in the day.
She's two and a half cause she's sitting there,
it's just,
she didn't,
she has juvenile rheumatoid arthritis.
So
that's what it was,
was built for was people with Ra.
Wow.
And so I brought her in there and you know,
before I'm like,
Oh,
you know me and me and Brittany went in there and I showed her pictures and they
said it gets really cold.
I said,
do you want to get cold?
And she's like,
no,
look at me like,
what are you,
are you stupid?
And I'm like,
okay.
And I kind of played it off and I brought her with me and then she was in there
for maybe 10 seconds,
I'm going to climb out the top.
So I ain't,
did it help her?
Um,
she's getting better.
She's only done it that one time.
I mean,
if I wasn't in Camp I would take her more.
But you know,
I,
my day is so,
you know,
scheduled that I don't have time to have a baby with me.
Yo could only two magical,
she has a lot of energy and she's really smart and everyone says her kids are
smart,
but she's pretty advanced and,
and it's hard,
man.
You,
we were talking about diet and things along those lines and you have to be very
careful with her diet.
She gluten free.
She,
uh,
I still give her some,
some,
uh,
I mean she doesn't drink milk,
but you'll have dairy through cheese,
red meat a little bit.
Um,
I,
that's why a big reason why I want to get into hunting because the meat is so
nutritious and they have so many friends that hunt.
I mean all my friends that played pro baseball hunt,
a lot of my,
you know,
fight or friends hunt,
just friends in general.
So you have,
you can to get some elk or some Moose,
some of the most nutritious meat you could give anybody.
My,
my Stepdad's a world renown hunter and tracker up in Alaska or it used to be in
Alaska.
Now he's with my mom and northern California and he's Jim Heroin.
He's 80 years old and like ex CIA Freemason.
Then it's practicing dentists,
just a murderer,
animals,
people,
whatever.
I got a polar bear ruck,
he has one for me and the polar bear rugs and he's fucking huge.
He's on anybody's freaking out right now.
Polar bears are not endangered danger 80 years old.
So he killed stuff a long time ago and he's just a,
he doesn't kill anymore.
I'm trying to talk them into taking me to Alaska one last time.
Did have you seen that show,
the hunt?
No.
It's a new show that James Hetfield from Metallica is the,
uh,
I watched bubble comics theater on Disney to be Ho Chi.
Last,
um,
James Hatfield is the commentator or the narrator and they go to Kodiak Island
where the biggest grizzly bears in the world live biggest brown bears in the
world.
And these bears are 10 feet fucking tall and these guys are hunting these 10
foot tall bear.
That's the kind of skin I have freaking out about.
Hetfield being a part is they wanted to remove him from the Glastonbury
music festival and everybody's angry.
And we know that if you love bears,
you got to kill the big Boris cause if you don't kill the big boards,
they eat babies.
Like people who don't understand bears or freaking out about that show.
Like they need to kill bears to keep the population healthy,
otherwise they're going to fuck each other up.
You know,
the first conservation were hunters because they were out there in the
wilderness going is,
you know,
this last section disappearing.
They knew they were out in the wild doing the Teddy Roosevelt was an avid hunter
and started the park system.
You know,
it's it.
People don't understand that.
It's just there's more deer today.
Then when Columbus landed in America,
and that's because of hunters and conservationists and like money for
conservation all comes from hunting license.
I need to kill them and eat them.
They're delicious.
I'll take you with me to delicious.
We'll go,
man dude,
I want to,
after you get out of camp,
I'll bring you,
me,
you,
me and Steve Rinella.
Rinella.
And I had been talking about doing that with the crush on him.
I do too.
He's awesome.
He's a sweetie.
He's a Haka and d is right now is a about to fight Ricardo,
the bully llamas and a really interesting fight.
Diaz is a bad motherfucker on the ground.
Got The model sobbing.
Sandra right there,
excellent Beltour fighter and that's a known as Bellah tour,
soon to be spike MMA if they're smart.
We will see.
Just call him and man,
just come in boxing.
Boxing doesn't have the battlers.
It's the battlers boxing series.
What is it?
It's boxing.
She's called fucking boxing,
you know.
Good point.
I just think we'll play.
It's mixed martial arts.
Everybody knows what it is.
Or here's the guy that's the same referee earlier that uh,
carry Hatley that fucked up
dark.
He was the guy who uh,
called it.
Hey.
All right.
Ricardo Lamas is just about to fight and if you're sinking this up at home,
we'll give you a,
the clock starts now.
Okay.
They just touch gloves just now.
All right,
here we go.
And Llamas just removed from his fight with Josie all though where he was
winning the fifth round had although down,
guess who moves?
Just like Aldo.
Alcorn d is same build,
real similar,
real similar Diaz,
great submission guy nine some McCreary submissions I think if I remember it
correctly.
Very good on the ground.
And also like a lot like Aldo is very competent standing up and not quite as
good but still very competent.
He's no joke.
Like,
it's no picnic.
Standing up with this guy.
Nice overhand,
right.
All those got like one of the best left hook,
right leg kicks in the business.
The yell it out,
do the Duchy do the Dutchy and he throws that,
that Holland combination man that left hook to the body,
right leg cape.
Oh Man.
I remember when he came out to,
uh,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna run this tonight,
but fought favor and that in Sacramento and it was just like,
oh,
you're an awesome.
Yeah.
That was one of the nastiest leg kicked.
Oh God.
That was Beverly.
Ever seen.
It was horrific.
And seeing his legs on Instagram after the fight where you're,
I kept taking pictures of his leg and it was up to literally twice the size.
It's not one month later and it was still not good.
I was like,
Bro,
you're right.
Randy coture told me that it took him six months to recover from the Pedro has a
fight.
Yeah.
That's what was so hard.
It was hard alliance that second fight and the first fight.
Most people who watch thought that Pedro one,
I thought he did.
Yeah.
A lot of people thought he did his old school and then Randy came back and beat
the fuck out of Pedro.
His own the second fight.
Thinking about those like,
it's like not today son.
His,
oh,
had a tendency to start slow in that costume.
[inaudible] you see those guys?
I came in the earth's kick a bag.
You know,
I used to go over to Marco's a little bit.
Who?
Oss and seeing those giant people kicked bags and stuff.
Oh my God.
I've never seen anybody kick anything harder than I've seen Pedro Huizar kick.
He kicked Rico Rodriguez once in their fight.
They're the most boring fight ever in the UFC was awful.
He kicked him once and Rico was like,
oh,
fuck all this,
walk this shit,
all this.
Nothing.
I don't think anything but a body shot in a lake kick.
I've seen fighters go,
fuck this.
I'm out.
I mean just mentally check out completely of a fight from those two things.
Ricoh was in full defense mode from then on and just said,
you know what?
No one's knocking me the fuck out.
You're not breaking my leg.
So let's,
uh,
let's just do what we gotta do here.
I'll collect my last Zuph a paycheck.
He made the agreement.
I won't try to win.
You don't try to hurt me.
And you can see when a fighter does that,
I won't try and beat you if you will let me have my legs.
There is a agreement.
They do it on time.
They do and you see it in their eyes,
man.
We see it all the time.
Yeah.
I will stop fighting if you won't hurt me.
It's a fascinating moment.
We see a guy break.
It's a fascinating and sometimes guys will break and then rebound and come back
and break and rebound and come back.
That sets where things get really interesting.
The,
the worst I think I've ever seen in between rounds was Dan Hornbuckle against
Ben Aspirin.
Ooh.
I was again like sat in that corner like,
and he's at a black belt in intensity and every now good Dan humbucker was,
and he came back to that and sat in his corner with his head down and just
didn't look like the same dude after one round and getting tossed around.
He just knew he was never going to catch up.
When you lock up with a guy like ascaris and you get costs all over the place
and every time you're trying to counter what he's doing,
he's already countering your counter.
He's one step ahead of you every time you down the whole time manhandling you.
And by the way,
he looks like he smokes pot all day and he's Cheetos dude.
He does it works at the seven 11 bro.
And he's kicking my ass kicking world clock.
He doesn't look like Kevin Randleman road.
You know,
if,
if he looked like Tyron Woodley,
you would understand it like I can't fuck with this guy.
But no,
he looks like a a silly stoner and he's just rag doll or had a little of that
and you're like,
Bro,
you do not look like you fight.
And he just get man dump dude.
The early days fade or win big when he was doing a lot of weightlifting and
that,
remember that picture of him standing around with a bunch of kettle bells.
This fucking him.
He's got some body fat
on him.
He always had body fat on him,
but he was fucking big.
I went back and watched the Fajita fight again the other day.
He was big.
He was way bigger than he was when he fought Dan Henderson.
Yeah.
By the time he fought Dan Henderson,
he kind of already checked out.
He was no longer know,
want more weights.
Oh I slept hook.
[inaudible] is and and uh,
Ricardo Lamas are going Outta here.
Diaz keeps landing that,
that overhand right.
That is a fight that a punch really kind of funny,
that big loopy over and you almost never see in box and you see it constantly in
MMA.
Yeah.
Cause those little gloves,
it can fit.
It always lands.
Why it's so interesting when you watch the uh,
the differences in the way guys cover up like in glory or in k one where so many
guys do that.
Classic Dutch.
Yeah.
Hold their hands up high guard.
Like you know,
up to the eyebrows oooooo hard leg kick at the Bell Diaz is that says this is a
tough fight for Ricardo Lamas.
As long as it's coming off a title fight,
would love to prove that he's still a top guy.
Not a lot to gain in this fight because Hakan Diaz is not a big name,
but he's a bad motherfucker.
Okay.
Is also no on same team.
I don't think.
They didn't talk about here's what I did.
Of course,
this is how you beat this guy.
Yeah.
Interesting that they all move the same too.
Like uh,
you know,
you see that in Borow too,
very similar in their movements.
The defensive like the way they,
I mean they,
they let loose a little different,
but it's like the defense is always the same,
just very tight.
It's pretty.
That's why I was so amazed at Tj Dillashaw so amazed.
I'd never seen a guy rise to the moment like that.
Good.
That,
that was incredible.
That was incredible.
It was one of the like,
like I thought,
well,
he can,
he's going to make it a good fight out of it.
It's really interesting.
Maybe you could win.
Who knows?
Who knows what's going to happen,
but you're dealing with a guy in Hanan Barao who was undefeated for nine years,
30 fucking fights without a loss and meanwhile TJ,
just random over random over after that,
that when he dropped him,
that was just,
he was,
he went back in the corner.
He had no idea what was going on.
When he was going into the fourth round,
he asked him if he was winning the fight.
He had no idea what was going on.
That is one of the scariest things to see as not just an MMA,
but you know,
football or whatever.
If a,
when you see someone's brain just get rewired and you go,
they're asking where they are.
They're asking one rounded.
They don't.
They just don't know what's going on.
Mad happens quickly and guys want on a for.
I've had people ask me,
did I,
what happened to fight?
They fought five rounds and they're going,
what happened?
You know what's scary?
Scary to look at it.
That's scary.
But that's post fight.
What's scary than that is a dude who's not even fighting,
who tells you the same story three times in 10 minutes and you go,
oh no.
Oh No.
I used to know you before you used to do this and now you're doing this.
Now you don't remember saying what you just said five minutes ago.
You're saying it again.
So Ricardo Lamas has Diaz is back here.
That's kind of,
and he's,
he's tried to take them down.
Wow.
Bold Ricardo Lamas.
Try to prove a point.
Good knees,
those land,
some good knees.
He's a good wrestler.
Llamas.
Yeah,
he is so fucking great ground and pound guy,
man.
It's ground up.
Pounds Nasty.
But this position is,
you're,
you know,
you're in a tricky spot here.
The other way to look at it though is,
is he not liking what he's seen on the feet?
Exactly.
A lot of those right hands,
that leg kick on the,
at the bell.
That was a hard way.
I was a good one.
Saw them around.
When a guy does something different,
you also go,
well,
what motivated him to do that for gold grade on the feet?
He wouldn't be doing that.
Yup.
Very good point.
And then gets away.
So Diaz gets away without a doubt.
He's looking for that kick.
Okay.
It's interesting too because uh,
the,
the big kick of Aldo was something that lamas really worried about going into
that fight or shouldn't say worried.
He knew that it was,
uh,
there was another one who I knew knew it was coming,
but did a really good job in defending,
I mean,
he was fine in the fifth round.
obviously he got tagged a bunch of times,
but you saw no noticeable limping.
He wasn't noticeably diminished because of it.
Yeah.
Okay.
But here he's just taking a few in this first round and the second he didn't
want,
he doesn't want and I was like kicks and what's funny is
we were talking a little about cornering and if a guys getting kicked in the leg
and they go in the corner,
it goes check the kicks,
checking.
If you haven't trained it,
it doesn't come fucking naturally.
You don't learn how to check in the middle of a fight.
You know where they go.
You know people ask me,
Oh,
should he start checking those kicks Mike?
If he hasn't been doing in training,
it's not going to work now.
It's really counterintuitive to like turn your Shin toward a guy was kicking
you.
It's never going to happen.
You're going to think about it and it will be too late.
It'll be too late,
man.
It's very tough to do.
It's like slipped the punches if you don't know how to sleep on
her hands up like anybody
vicious left hook too.
Damn.
Oh Man.
Why was this still in?
It is an animal.
That was a nice combination.
Yeah,
he's,
he was in trouble there.
The kid has tremendous resolve.
Tremendous mental resolve.
Look at this pillow take down.
Yeah.
And as a little tire it takes a big deep breath right there.
Thinking about that.
That can be a little disheartening.
Hitting somebody with a punch like that and they come right back at you.
Hit him with suck.
Read three mean ones,
three clean ones.
Do you think there's too many fighters in MMA right now for the amount of fights
that are available?
Too many fighter.
Too many.
You know people were talking about the UFC has 500 fighters.
I don't know how many belts or has,
but they just cut you guys.
They just cut a bunch.
They cut a hundred fighters.
Holy Shit,
I didn't know that.
Yup.
19 or 20 you know Scott Coker,
just clean shop.
Scott said,
I think Scott's going to run that shit.
Very smart guy.
Very different.
Very good guides.
A lot of changes.
Really like universally liked.
Yeah.
Which is
unheard of in the fight world.
Hard,
So can you say universally liked with Dana White?
I like Dana.
I like him a lot.
He's one of my good friends.
I love the guy but shit,
I mean you can go on the underground any day.
Well you can find threads about anybody,
any hate threads on the underground.
I get hit me all the time.
Oh minor that I'm trying to love a lot of love.
I love,
loved the underground and you know people like,
like got upset with me this week because I was saying like there's too many
douche bags on online and I've been avoiding going to forums.
Like I get a lot out of the underground but it's just like the Douche bags want
to stay douche bags.
They just want to stay assholes.
And all I'm saying is if you had a guy over your party and he was talking to
people like that and when you want them to be gone.
Yeah,
that's what would an online forum is.
It's a party and they want it to be open to anybody and they don't want any
repercussions of their Douche,
Enos.
They don't want to take responsibility for the way people react to the way they
behave.
Where Carl Lamas going?
Coming back at Diaz here,
man.
Okay.
Is a tough motherfucker.
Man was good combinations.
Man's recovered from those shots.
Oh,
Dee has cracked him again though.
It's moving his feet now.
He's actually doing flips,
you know,
angles.
Yeah.
Two rounds in exciting fight.
But uh,
you know,
forums are great,
man.
I get a lot of the underground,
I get a lot of discussion.
It's just like sometimes you'll chop on there and deal,
just run into a wave of comments just to just to a one Wavell hitch and some
guys just check out.
They're like,
all right,
I'm,
I'm done with this place.
Yeah.
I tried to say that like you guys ran off almost all the fighters.
There's very few guys still post there anymore and people get upset.
Ooh,
food can we make goes good?
They're just doing want to hear the truth and no,
no,
no.
Did your just to kind of,
you're being dead.
Yeah.
He's just being,
you're saying something when you're talking to a guy,
like whatever,
it's Brian,
Stan or anybody you're talking in a way online that you would never talk to
them.
If they're standing in front of you,
I'll fucking slap.
He'd have to be,
or you'd have to be in a complete sociopath would if you were bigger than them
and you talk to them like that.
Like why would you talk to someone like that that you don't even,
you don't even know the guy personally.
You don't have a relationship with them.
You might think you know him if you want to be critical of his technique or his
performance,
there's a way to do it respectfully.
You can even be funny.
Yeah,
exactly.
If we're going to make it funny,
it's then cool.
Have Fun and the,
at least,
if you're going to be a dick,
be funny and make me laugh.
You'll look,
I don't like a lot of those uh,
mean photoshops but some of them are fucking hilarious of dudes that are Kol and
they say,
it says some fucked up shit.
Like there was some really funny ones that people did about Rashad Evans.
I like Rashad a lot,
but the,
the mirror pretty fight.
They were funny.
You know,
there's,
that's where you could see an argument.
You could say,
well,
you know,
like I've seen a lot of photoshops of me and very disrespectful,
but I think they're hilarious and I don't want to stop them at all.
I've seen photoshops with me surrounded by Dicks,
you know,
with a little,
a tiny woman's body wearing girl's underwear.
I've seen everything and I never have a problem with it.
I think it's funny,
as long as it's fucking key.
Becoming as photos of Dixon owns in Photoshop [inaudible] by Dixon.
It's weird.
It was just Tuesday,
my buddy goes on on Diaz again.
Welcome to early MMA.
Right?
Seriously,
I get a lot of criticism though.
I really do.
I get a lot out of,
um,
just even if I don't agree with like them being hypercritical,
you see a point of view,
you know,
you see their point of view and maybe you see how it was back.
Oh Yeah,
look at this Lama.
So she is back.
This is incredible.
He's got a full naked,
they could choke.
I can't.
We can't sell DVDs from here,
but look at it.
He's trying to go palm to palm.
Oh,
he might have his on his fucking Chin and he did.
What Ronda Rousey did with e.
Dot.
Him.
He let go of the defense of the neck just to get rid of the hooks and then threw
them off.
Wow.
Strong confidence in his neck.
The number one thing I get is that I'm trying to be you.
It's a number one criticism that we're number one asshole thing.
I get to express.
I'm trying to be Joe Rogan.
Why?
What?
They don't know his head shaved years.
Years ago.
I totally copied.
You can since high school.
True Story.
My Mom's slot.
Lama says the fucking kids.
He now on these going to get it.
Oh Man.
It's amazing though that he's the one who's threatening with chokes.
He's cat to real close submissions.
Where's DSA and had shit on him.
I see Black Belt Cochran or Ricardo?
Ricardo.
Ricardo's.
Yeah.
Your hotline is a big black posts,
but that's their,
their criticisms are ridiculous.
You just get excited like I do.
Everybody sees somebody hit get goes,
oh,
that's what you do.
It's funny,
man.
My mom wants got US mixed up.
I'm not kidding.
Literally watched it.
I was literally watching UFC at my mother's house.
She was making dinner.
It's just phenomenal cook or are there,
she's making it and I'm watching UFC and she comes in the room in the living
room.
She goes,
oh,
it's one of your fights.
I go,
no,
mom,
Miss Joe Rogan.
It looks like you.
And I asked him off.
My fucking mom got US mixed up.
Oh Dad.
It was funny.
I was laughing.
It's funny.
That's hilarious.
We're,
but you know,
White Guy Tattoos.
You know?
Why can't I see it?
The same shape.
No hair.
Who Yell a lot.
Yeah,
we do.
Yo,
a part of our job was,
that's entertaining then.
That's another thing about you and I that I really enjoy the fact that we're
very friendly.
We'd like to turn the best friends and we're supposed to be like,
come splatter the enemies.
We're supposed to eat while I'm in there,
I guess,
which is ridiculous.
I tried to get the UFC to hire him.
I totally did.
I really did,
but when I told Dana White,
I had a conversation with them.
I said,
the guy is awesome.
I go,
I think he's the best guy out there.
I really think he's really good.
I go,
UFC should hire him.
I don't know when his contract is up,
but you guys should find out.
So they looked in.
They found that when his contract was up and then they even started like trying
to get them.
But then Viacom,
there's a lot of money being involved.
Lawyers,
lawsuits threatened.
Did you get paid more?
Anyhow,
he scared me.
Really scare
me.
Eddie Alvarez.
Ooh,
look at this.
Look at this.
He's a fucking chore.
Control
inside control.
Okay.
Incredible.
Incredible performance on the ground by llamas.
Lost the over under.
Oh,
when he gets tagged by a Reit,
how Awkward d is embarrassed right now.
Must be embarrassed.
You look at this lamas on top of him.
Good Cardio by llamas.
Huh?
He's coming back.
Nice kick to the body.
He's just aggressive the whole time.
But yeah,
I really wanted the UFC to hire Jimmy,
you know?
Um,
if I did even less events,
I don't know.
I like watching it at home.
I'm happy with that.
But there's so many events that they're doing now.
They're doing two a day.
A lot two of them happened today.
One of them was in New Zealand and this one here is happening in San Antonio to
different teams.
You know,
they had anak and I'm Florian are doing this one or anak and Stan and Stan
Florian and Goldie got shipped off to New Zealand
for a fight pass.
Marquardt looked fucking great.
Mark Clark looked really good.
It was a nap.
The arm bar.
He said TRT issues.
Did those get cleared up or no?
Am I going to find out someday?
I guess we're gonna find out soon.
You never know.
Take it.
The vet a couple of hours.
It is,
yeah.
I told somebody a couple days ago,
it's,
there wasn't a lady who swallowed a fly.
I remember that poem.
Yes,
she swatted,
swallowed a spider to catch a fly.
Just fall to bird swallow the spider.
Once you start doing,
oh,
I was on this because I was on TRT because I did this,
I was getting bitches,
I'd take this.
So it's just an endless stream.
When you start messing with that man,
it's an endless stream of shit.
Yeah.
And that's where shale wells and so it's out on bloody elbow.
So we can talk about it,
right?
Yes,
we can cause jail.
Um,
he's in a situation now where,
uh,
he got popped for a bunch of different shit that he was taking to try to recover
from the fact that he was on TRT.
And then what people people don't understand is when you get off a tee,
TRT,
your body takes a long time to recover and get back to a point where it's
producing a natural level of testosterone.
So guys take things to try to reboot their system.
And the things that he tested positive for from the Nevada state athletic
commission were in those groups.
The groups have a estrogen inhibitors that they use to try to boost your
testosterone.
But they,
the UFC,
they went through the most comprehensive drug testing that they could possibly
get.
This thing that costs $45,000 per fighter.
And uh,
the guy shows up,
takes the blood,
leaves in a suitcase,
they have a chain of custody of the blood,
flies with it on a plane.
Like he's fucking handcuffed to it.
Like it's a,
like the nuclear button.
Nuclear codes.
Yeah.
And they did this to jail and he tested positive for HGH and EPO,
which are not part of that group now for post a testosterone therapy.
So he had h,
g,
h she had EPO and then he had
clomiphene and Anna Straws.
So on a struggle.
So apparently what,
you know what I think it is,
is he was just trying to just do something to jack up a system,
get,
get the fucking fires burning.
But how many guys are on each change?
A ton.
Is it 90% what is it?
Is it 60 what's the number?
You know,
it's a lot.
A lot of guys aren't HGH.
Why?
Drum roll.
Cause it was,
it works weird.
Yeah.
There's a lot of stuff that that works.
And for years it wasn't testable.
Now yeah,
they,
they have developed that test,
but at it being that expensive,
they can't use it on everybody.
If it's 45 grand a pop,
the,
they're gonna use it on everybody.
Really.
I mean,
I think anytime they get no Ricardo lamas that alarm us.
I think he deserved it.
Fuck yeah.
He took that fight.
Did,
I'm just amazed that he got his back like that.
I'm amazed as he,
yeah.
He got his bell rung and rung and kept coming and he took some nasty fucking
punch.
Those steps.
One,
two,
three combination that he got hit with then immediately secured that clinch.
He's a real fighter man.
Oh Man.
My masters,
by the way,
the coach behind them and my master's is a coach.
They're a team out of south Florida.
Uh,
we were wondering about that before his team and everything's out of south
Florida.
That's where he's at now.
He's a Chicago guy.
I think so,
but I know MMS,
MMA masters out of south Florida.
Yeah.
He um,
she caught him on a handbrake on?
No,
no,
that was just the end of the fight.
I don't know what that is.
I'm looking at his hand if what they're talking about that um,
we can't really hear the auto in here by the way.
People,
yeah.
Well I mean we could,
but then that runs into weird issues.
Like if we were,
um,
if we were doing this,
well the,
the thing is it's not totally legal.
It's kind of on Fox.
Like we would,
we would kind of be broadcast and other stuff kind of pirating and I kind of
worked for Fox,
kind of looked down on that.
They frown upon that.
Nobody's told me to not do this,
but when I told them I was doing this,
then what?
This can be a fucking,
he might say some fucked up shit or have a guy like Ian Mccall on will say,
say fucked up shit.
Oh good.
Good for Ricardo.
Lamas stole.
Cause that's a fight where he had a lot to lose and not a lot to gain.
And he was late.
He was losing and he wasn't in the beginning.
That was a great fight.
Very good fight for him.
So,
um,
we were talking about glory earlier kid,
right?
That can we take them in the Ted?
I appreciate that.
Gets a kid with bad data.
The Facebook,
George Saint Pierre,
and he was a kid.
There's a good legs kicks and again,
look,
what do they show when they've tried to repay the replay?
It looks like it's the Ricardo Lamas show.
They don't show any of a wood hoc.
Ron Diaz did.
Ricardo Lamas takes him down here.
Ricardo Lamas Hits Him with a jab.
Come on man.
In a very competitive fight.
The move of the fight,
I think the moves or fight move of the fight should be both.
I'm going to talk to them about that.
The next event we'll see if you listen to me.
Got Juice,
right?
You got to listen to you.
I've been around.
Everybody ignores me and know some things.
My friend.
Is that Joe Stevens?
Yup.
What's Joe Up to these days?
Joe Daddy.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Joe.
Steven.
Hey.
That kid started his MMA career as a professional.
Six 16 years old man's Chris Brennan choked him out in UFC when he was 1616
years old on fucking in the cage or UFC.
It was king in the cage.
So first year was the first king of the cage.
Okay.
It was.
Yeah.
And that they tried to get me to fight when I was 16 or king of the cage.
He beat up Joe Camacho,
his first fight.
So crazy tough.
Joe Camacho.
Rustin please.
Yeah.
Couldn't believe that.
I'm a former teammate of mine.
He was a good dude.
He was alert Joe Chasy plenty dude would fight anybody anytime.
Anywhere.
Good Dude too,
man.
That's another thing that's kind of gone.
Understandably.
I get it.
But yeah,
you know,
there was a few of those guys and a lot of them have crap records cause they
would fight anywhere.
Chris Brennan give him a call,
he'll show up,
he'll fight.
Man,
Daddy,
give him a ring.
You know,
they'll show up,
they'll know those show up,
you know,
they'll fight and they'll have,
20 losses.
They don't give a shit that fucking knock out of Weidman versus Silva.
That just showed him the replay.
I watch it.
I've seen it a hundred times.
I still don't believe it's happening.
I just go,
there's no way.
There's no way that's real.
It's like you remember what buster Douglas knocked out Mike Tyson and you watch
the replay like 10 times in a row.
You're like,
that didn't happen.
Yeah.
This is,
I'm watching a Hologram.
Yeah.
Upset in boxing history.
Crazy,
crazy upset in my opinion.
But when you watch it,
you know,
it doesn't seem real like I got when I watch Hanan Barao Tj Dillashaw,
I've watched it again.
It seems real.
You know,
Tj put on a masterful performance,
but I believe it,
when I watched Weidman connect with that left hook,
I'm like,
is this a parallel universe?
Is this something,
am I in a dream that really happened?
I cried and I was,
me and my brother cried when Tyson lost.
Did you,
why?
What happened to Daddy?
My Dad,
we watched and we steam still watches every UFC,
every boxing.
He knows his shit and it's awesome.
And he just,
uh,
I remember,
oh my God,
Superman just died
when he was struggling to put that mouthpiece backend.
Mother fucker was came to the end though.
Still trying to put his mouthpiece but an ad on a shield Scra scrunching around
the ground,
try and get that thing in his mouth.
Speaking of awful corners.
Aaron Snow,
they didn't bring an end swell water bag,
blubber glove full of ice ice water shit ever.
No.
Oh my God.
They didn't have an end swell and that was,
you know,
we were talking about cornering.
Go out and Mike,
you go,
all right,
Mike,
move your head.
You sitting here with you.
I mean there were,
there wasn't technical things that anybody could have told him and they lived,
just had no idea what to do.
That's a kid always beating everybody else is a perfect example of a guy
learning from fantastic coaches and then thinking he doesn't need any more
coaching.
Kevin Rooney,
amazing coach Kevin Rooney was amazing.
And before that customer pulled a gun on him
at tends to dampen the relationship.
You're not supposed to fuck Teddy's nice Mike.
Yeah.
Generally
cornering his knees that you know,
you want to read a bad idea.
Fucking beast.
Fucking savage.
Jeez.
Can't believe leaving a little girls around my Tyson either.
By the way,
speaking of scenes where you go,
did I just see that?
You know the interview he did before the Lennox fight,
when there's a woman reporter and she says something goes,
are you talking on a turn?
And she goes,
I thought we were all just talking.
It was,
cause I usually don't do interviews with women list.
So fornicate with me.
It's,
you should stop talking now and who's go did I did I just see that?
Hey,
he's cool.
Savage.
Oh fuck you.
Tell you left.
Fuck you until you love me.
Faggot.
Oh,
running crazy.
Scared of white bitch.
Oh my God.
Scared Mailman.
Ah,
use you for real man.
Well,
when you hear him now he talks about how much coke he was doing it.
Seriously.
I'll eat his babies.
Remember that?
Prayed for me.
I want to eat his children.
I'm for riches.
My defects is impregnable.
I'm Jack Dempsey.
Oh,
John Sentence for roses.
Have you a chip.
It never lived precocious.
Yeah,
that was,
those were the days,
man.
Those were the days.
What do they show in the Weidman versus Liotta Machita fight.
What do you think about this?
Do you think that he's gonna be able to get ahold of Mitchell?
Machida is tough for anybody.
He's just his style,
his Kryptonite.
And I have a tremendous respect for,
for uh,
everybody.
He's five.
It's just you just can't get a handle on Machida.
He's so hard to get a handle on,
on man.
Why am I not as bad?
Knees to man real bad.
And he's fought through it because he's incredibly tough.
But he had Regena keen done on both of his knees.
Um,
and then after he had Regena keen done,
he felt great and then fucked him up again and then had to get meniscus surgery.
So he got meniscus surgery on both knees and it wasn't that long ago.
And that's what canceled his last fight.
That's what postpone the fight.
And then,
you know,
obviously he was supposed to fight Vito or Vito had to pull out.
They still have a veto,
apparently still has to get licensed.
And tested and all that jazz,
but he's another one of those guys off the testosterone replacement and you
know,
now what,
especially with this new ruling,
when they found out,
now that everybody knows that shale signing got popped and now that everybody
knows that he got popped with this,
this new testing that they're doing,
it's $45,000 testing.
Who's scrambling right now?
That's what I'm wondering about is who's right up on,
oh shit.
There's dudes are scrapped a lot of motherfuckers that are like,
oh,
especially a lot of guys,
especially the older guys,
it's been anybody that was on it.
I mean anybody that,
I mean there was,
there was only a handful of guys that were officially on testosterone
replacement,
but they're all fucked.
I mean,
Dan Henderson is the only one who's,
who's been able to fight on it and off it with very similar results.
Like he fought a Rashad Evans,
he was off of it because Winnipeg have a sanctioning.
They didn't sanction testosterone replacement.
So Dan apparently only takes a little bit of it,
so he's like,
I just won't take it.
So he just fought without it and did didn't,
it wasn't like a sweeping difference between how he looked.
Yeah.
Dan's a guy by the way,
personally,
and he's training a little bit and Dan's a great guy.
I really liked him.
I really don't want to see,
have that fight where he suddenly old.
I just hope he gets out before then cause he's looked okay.
I mean he's looked good.
It just,
I don't want him to have that fight.
I just,
I just really don't want to see it as a,
as a,
as a fan.
I really don't want to see that fight,
man.
Well he's got a chin that's made out of some new kind of metal and it's like
they don't even know what her in Shit.
Yeah.
It doesn't even make sense.
I never seen a guy take shots.
Like he takes shots.
He's got the best Chin I've ever seen in my life.
I mean,
I've seen him get rocked.
Anderson rocked him.
Anderson lit them up with like a four or five punch combination before he,
uh,
Kot him or for you.
I choked him out.
Rather he,
he's the first guy that I've ever seen hurt Dan like that.
But Dan's been in some crazy ass fucking wars.
Really tenderly and pride the dog shit out of him.
And the first fight in the first fight,
the dog shit out of him,
beat the dog shit out of him going and he fucked Vandelay up to his back.
That's what Vandelay was just if you just,
if you had a steroid test and you brought it near him,
it would explode.
It would start shaking in your hands.
[inaudible]
a black hole would be created.
Yeah.
Like,
cause you're fucking screwed.
Like a memorex commercial.
When they yell,
they sing in the fucking glass break.
It would just,
it would just fucking explode.
So he got rocked with a big punch and Dan caught him with a huge right hand,
fucked his eye up.
Remember vandelays I was completely caught up.
And by the way,
he was fighting.
It was like he needed even notice it didn't even care.
Didn't even care.
I don't think enough people,
and this is,
I really believe this cro cop beat the career out of Vendelay Silva.
I believe he did shoot him so badly in pride,
Grand Prix heavyweight.
I don't think Manderlay was ever the same dude after that.
Beat the career out of them.
There's that was Vandelay that one fight man.
Vandelay was trying to fight a 214 pounds again,
juice to the Gig.
No Big Gig kills.
You wouldn't piss hot.
He would piss liquid steroid.
Like you can drink that.
He's gained 10 pounds.
Get home.
You'd be like,
why am I so food?
You can eat Vander lane dude.
But his wife was all jacked up.
She grew up,
she grew a beard.
Yeah.
Delay was,
was a monster.
I mean he was just not afraid of anybody.
But that was when,
for those of you who hasn't see it,
dude,
it's,
it's uh,
an ass whooping from the beginning to end.
There's an ass scary person back then
and he fucked Vandelay up before he killed him.
He had to do,
was it up?
He never been the same.
So good.
But then again,
he's another guy will do,
we're all,
look,
when you talked to ensign anyway,
he said had contracts that said they don't test for steroids.
Like contracts are telling you they're not going to test it with steroids.
Yeah.
You know the ends and laughs about it.
Yeah,
but you look at it didn't give a fuck like cro cop and he comes over to the UFC
and he's just never the fucking same.
Not the same guy.
Everybody goes,
yeah,
private photos weren't that good.
The kiln you'll see him got smoked and I'm like number one,
a couple of them one bell.
It's like going to throw on rampage but gee you think I know they were just
juiced the gills to the gills man.
And we all know that you can only have so many of those fucking fights.
The reason they were big in practice,
he had 20 of you know,
20 fights against top guys and everybody now is like a pride fan.
Like it's like cool to be a pride fan.
Yeah.
They had some freak show fights that made no sense that a lot of,
I love prime old school pride fan,
but a lot of those fights were like,
they would throw,
got member dies,
you're Matsui.
They would just throw him to this.
Anybody who was against anybody.
It's like you can't take that number of beatings or just hard fights period and
and have a career after that.
Like it's just Sakuraba.
I mean that,
and they gave him no love dude.
Like after he was,
you know,
after,
basically after he lost the valley's second time,
it was clear that he was going to be mentally then it was cro cop.
It was just,
they never gave the guy a break,
man.
That the one time I saw him was that Soboba King of the cage and he was drinking
and smoking cigarettes.
Well,
apparently he always smoked.
Smoked when he was in training,
it gets supplements is what he said.
Oh really?
No,
no,
no.
He just,
that's when you called them.
It's amazing how good his cardio was.
Yeah.
The guy never gassed out and never smoke cigarettes all the time.
It's like,
what's his name from Nicaragua?
The boxer there.
The guy who
tried a little bit of a MMA holds go chat and yeah,
it's just a smoke cigarettes.
Romi Romi from my gym.
It's,
he just smokes,
eats gristle and drinks alcohol.
Really?
And he just like,
he knew when he,
he never gets tired of punching.
He'd take it for a run.
You don't run them into the ground.
It's easy,
but giant punch with them and blah blah blah,
blah,
blah.
I'm like,
dude,
we just went five fives and you're still punching faster than when you smoke
cigarettes.
You smoked cigarettes every day.
A lot of Thai guys do.
Right?
Yeah.
The ties a lot of the times he tried cigarettes with,
with the foreigners.
That's so hilarious to get some foreign cigarettes.
Yeah.
So this is a Saiza for who won the ultimate fighter Brazil.
Um,
he's coming off of that knockout.
Lost a CB.
Dalloway though,
right?
Wasn't that as last fight?
Dalloway caught him?
I don't think so.
Beautiful Punch it.
Start.
Dolly's standup is much improved and a,
this is an interesting fight,
man.
Andrew Craig,
who's another one of those guys that's a an athlete in other sports that came
into MMA late in life.
Okay.
He played football.
Where did he do?
I don't remember.
Okay.
I don't remember what he did.
I wish I had my cheat sheet in front of me.
Okay.
10.
I'm smart.
I fought with them in Brazil.
Did you?
Yeah.
Or not presenting that in Australia.
Shipping this guy.
I cut way together.
Yeah.
Very good dude.
Tough guy too,
man.
I loved how he looked against Chris Leben.
That was one of the signs that it was over for Lieben.
Yeah,
because Andrew Craig avoided all Lievens charges and fought with it for a him.
Them.
Okay
for arrows trying to lock up.
Anaconda choked right away.
Oh,
look at his army and a teen.
He loves that arm and Guillotine to man.
He got that army Ganti and in one of his last fights,
he hops over to the side,
gets his hips on the side and traps the Arman with his hips.
We were just talking about this last night.
Yeah.
With some MMA,
Jujitsu guys at the Ice House about that gates.
You know a lot of guys are doing that now.
They trap that Armin and jump off to the side.
You can circle and go Peruvian too.
[inaudible] yeah,
yeah.
I liked the Peruvian necktie.
Yeah.
Now he's saw switching it up to that 10 finger.
Nope.
Angie's got those hand separated.
Let's see if Andrew goes to his back.
Cause that's the thing.
A lot of dudes don't want to give up the back.
You know.
And Andrew stood back up.
Nicely done by Craig.
Andrew Craig's got to get rid of that crazy beard.
Look at that.
It looks,
it looks very uncle creepy.
Like
there's one of us can have that motherfucker.
Don't get mad.
No tests.
Twirly up the tips of his mustache.
Then you going to have to talk,
talked with them.
Listen,
son Eddie Wineland
it does it.
Does he?
Yeah,
he's,
I'll get my head.
It does.
Yeah.
When does he do it?
And I never saw him do that.
Yeah.
I don't know if he still has it.
I know he's had it before in the past.
What'd you think about his last fight?
How do you find that?
He,
um,
I got knocked out.
Remember?
Oh,
by a Brazilian cat?
Yeah.
Young one,
isn't it?
Yeah.
I'll pull it up.
Okay.
He might retire,
which sucks because he's got his job broken.
Yup.
Yeah.
I hate to get wired.
I love watch that guy fired.
He's exciting.
You want to talk about God never keeps his fucking hands up.
Yeah.
You just sling.
So I mean he moved his head real good.
Good footwork Johnny.
Eduardo knocked him out.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's cut bad.
Look at that.
His blood running down the side of his face.
Yeah.
It's a good spot though.
At the top has had corn rows,
like a fucking white check hanging out with black dudes or in Cabo.
Cabo.
Yeah.
Bo Derek Fan low.
Derek.
Man,
it's an old school.
And what's going on?
I got poked too.
God Damn.
I hate these high pokes.
Now here's the thing.
It's something that Abella Tor is doing good.
I like that new glove that you guys have other than Jimmy Smith.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's the main thing.
That's the main thing.
Good.
That Jimmy Smith Guy,
that guy works with questionable
at the gloves,
those new Everlast gloves that are are,
they protect the hand bore and they're more curved.
The other kind of bent.
If you haven't seen them,
they're kind of like make a hand couple of them I would.
Sure.
Like some more hand protection.
Yeah.
And
I know you use,
Dean's got a fucked up hand right now.
How many times he had hand surgery twice.
Brett's
a two surgeries.
Two breaks.
Uh,
and it's just,
I mean it will break again.
It's just one of those things you say too hard son.
Got a problem.
Right?
People in the top of that,
that's a problem as the killer.
This a good straight lamp by for that.
Um,
the Everlast glove,
they've had very few handbrakes in Beltour since,
since that was implemented.
Right.
What was the statistic?
Jimmy,
you're the guy over there.
I am the guy over there.
What are the numbers,
Jimmy,
for the amperage?
Six.
About what?
Yeah,
what's your specific question?
Well,
there was a bunch of them.
There was a statistic.
Look how small retort Belfort's aren't looks.
I mean,
I don't want to be the guy saying that,
just throwing that out there that
get rid of that guys,
they're heard us in the truck.
Um,
I know that there was like a ton of handbrakes one season,
the season before the implementation of these gloves.
And since then I don't think there's been a break.
I haven't seen one.
I think,
yeah,
I think they've like literally eliminated handbrakes which is,
I mean it's kind of anecdotal.
It's not like a,
well the problem,
the problem they've hadn't belter and,
and obviously it's,
it's going to change next year as well.
The tournament system guy would get his hand broken and that was it.
We had thrown somebody out like an injury.
We would go,
okay,
well he won't fight for four months anyway.
Now he's got to find a month.
Yeah.
So that's why they don't allow elbows on the ground.
It's because,
or the LLS period,
it's because they didn't want cuts where you get a 60 day suspension,
you can't fight the next month.
So that would really fuck belts were up.
So when people got injured,
fight in a month,
you've got a broken hand,
you don,
I mean it's just,
you gotta replace them.
Do you think that they're going to change that fight in a month?
Thing with coke involved?
Cause I think that they're getting rid of the tournament,
yes.
Thing.
Yes.
They uh,
the seasonal format where we're doing a fight a week for three months is going
to go,
um,
that's what they're talking about because essentially a one time until the
story,
a Marinello used to call me every week to do when he was on the score and radio
show or whatever and to kind of break down next week's bell torn one time.
He goes,
all right,
well in three weeks.
And I went,
Oh shit,
I'm not,
I don't know what's happening in three weeks.
Like that's like a year to me,
you know,
that's like four or five years from now.
So I like running my computer and like pull it up real quick so I can talk about
it.
I don't know what's happening in two weeks or three weeks.
How has,
how have the fans get to know what's happening?
We like you couldn't build up a fight because we had a fight every week.
So unless you were like in it,
cause you like watching fights every week.
We did have those fans that,
that got into it.
Like you get into a,
to these TV series.
It was hard to hype a fight and make a fight really big.
And Scott Coker,
his whole thing now is big fights and you need lead time and you need
promotional time to build those up.
Yeah.
It can't be done every week.
So by the way,
nobody gives a fuck about tournaments.
They like,
they're like,
here's the,
here's the statistics.
And so,
you know,
the new gloves debuted at Beltour one 10 and Bella Torah has held nine events
and experiences zero handbrakes
since uh,
the implementation of the new drug.
New gloves by comparison,
Bella tour season eight saw 11 events.
You'd the old use the old glove design and included eight broken hands,
including welterweight champion,
Douglas Lema,
a beast,
a dude's a monster and a lightweight standouts.
Assad a wad is that I say this,
I had a one side a wad and broke it against Dave Rickles and Alexander
Karnofsky.
Yeah.
All broke their hand.
Imagine amazing man.
Amazing.
I remember those fights.
Season nine also featured 11 events and had seven fighters suffer breaks.
Hold on a second.
Season Eight.
Okay.
This is,
this is thing.
Season eight had the new gloves and Oh,
they had eight broken hands.
Okay.
Hold on a second.
Wait a second.
Since the new glove,
they've held nine events.
Okay.
Bellator season eight saw 11 events with the old gloves to,
to deny your understanding that the confusion of the season format.
Now right here,
Joe,
is just simplifying that.
Okay.
Well apparently they haven't had Henny handbrakes since the new gloves.
I didn't know that.
We haven't any sense.
They had the new one.
That's incredible.
That's pretty cool.
That's pretty amazing.
So if you see the gloves,
you see them,
uh,
in an image,
you can see him here.
The comparison between the old gloves and the new gloves,
they're just thicker,
thicker on top.
And not an Eli,
not any heavier.
Right.
It's still four ounce gloves.
Listen.
All right,
so Andrew,
Craig,
Cesar for [inaudible] finding the second round here and Bhutanese fucking huge
for 185
yeah,
lean was one of those guys.
You look at him,
you go,
how the fuck do you make 170 pounds?
He is a giant.
Was that guy walk around at two 20 Jesus.
Seriously,
north of two.
Well,
north of 200 it's well north of a perfect example of a guy who diminished by
losing weight.
Is is uh,
Anthony Rumble Johnson.
He's the best example.
Yeah,
look at what the fuck that guy looks like as a light heavyweight.
He's gotta be kicking himself for not being a light heavyweight all along.
He's a scary having full energy and full what he did.
Phil Davis,
nobody's done the Phil Davis.
He manhandled him,
handled them,
stuffed every takedown.
Like it was a joke.
Beat the shit out of him standing,
made it look like he didn't belong in there with them.
It was amazing.
I can
power wise what were shot beat Phil Davis,
but physically didn't do it like that.
The floor with them.
Didn't do it like that.
Anthony Rumble Johnson is fucking frightening.
Yeah.
It's a scary dude.
So Andrew Craig and [inaudible] here in the second round.
So yeah,
Ferrara did a,
he lost his last fight.
That was a,
the doll with Hud.
Yeah.
That was the doorway fight,
which was a great fight for,
uh,
for Dalloway.
Dollo is another one of those guys that are really is coming into his own
lately.
He just starting to see it.
Dalloway is just starting to get real comfortable with his hands were loose with
his hands
spinning back fist.
It's interesting how you're seeing,
like,
like we were talking about this the other day,
that MMA has a lot of,
like,
one guy will do one thing and you'll see it happen.
You'll see it'd be effective,
like a wheel kick.
And then you'll see like everybody throwing wheels.
Everybody's trying it.
Yeah.
It's one of those things,
we'll get this holy Shantay strong as fuck.
Good takedown defense by Craig though.
Andrew Craig's a really good athlete,
man.
And the reason why he's gotten so good at MMA so quickly,
it's,
it's not the,
uh,
technique anymore is the x factor is how good of an athlete are there.
That's definitely a part of it,
right?
I mean,
Marcello Garcia has always said that about no Jujitsu,
that the difference she know g and g is that physical attributes are so much
more important and no gay.
That a guy who was really physically strong,
it counts for so much more.
Whereas the guys physically strong and a g,
you know,
we,
we've,
we've all seen it guys get wrapped up in spider webbed,
you know,
they just get gummed up.
Ted Today took second in the world.
That heavyweight did.
He really had heavyweight lost too.
Fibery silver dome on points.
That's incredible.
Heavyweight and heavyweight [inaudible] obviously.
Yeah,
I mean that's how good ted today was.
I mean this guy fought for the non Jujitsu people,
fought around 170 pounds.
Schooled Marcel,
see you in the world,
I think 2003 2004
with a geek.
So that's a perfect example is the guy,
you know,
I've seen Jeff Glover school heavyweights with a g,
but anything Mary g off man.
Yeah.
That's why a lot of guys like Charlie,
you own the Geeky make,
you'll technical my friend.
You know you're going to train for MMA but you'll learn train negi why they want
to do that.
Cause when they roll with you they get still wrap you up in Brazilian Jujitsu.
You're Brazilian accent is is incredible by the way.
It's not bad.
My friend Nova is normal.
I've been around,
you know,
do this guy with these guys.
You know,
Jujitsu is very good.
Very true.
Stays Ferrara.
We'll we'll kick that was like the company talks about it,
dropped down and put his hands on the ground and everything.
Andrew Craig looks a very v for vendetta.
He does.
He's doing the wrong thing though,
is when for us throwing the wild techniques,
he's freezing.
Craig's kind of looking at it right now.
That's the time to get on the guy,
you know,
but straight shots,
straight shots and right now he's seeing the funky techniques and freezing.
Yeah.
Looking at it.
He's still got a lot of,
a lot of growing to do know.
I mean the,
it's hard for a guy who's getting into MMA late in life with no expertise in
anything.
It's one,
one thing if you're like a cro cop guy,
there was a high level kickboxer enters into MMA and then you,
you,
we get to watch the,
the transition.
But these guys that are learning everything as they go along.
Yeah.
Do you think he could a data girl like Rhonda Rousey,
Jimmy Smith,
if you were a single guy date,
let's,
let's use some word finishes here.
I use the word date.
A lot of people were being nice or being nice here.
Could I date?
Yes.
Could you,
could you,
could that be your girlfriend?
They can handle that crazy.
And I,
well,
it's weird because I tend to attract a lot of crazy women.
Uh,
no way.
Yeah,
I don't believe in,
Oh man,
this room.
Yeah.
Seriously.
Ever do you mean?
He's like,
it's not even my fault.
Not Crazy.
I'm not interested.
But yeah,
I'm seriously.
Then
when we get to talk about,
I'm crazy.
If you're not crazy,
you're not.
At least a little nuts is not going to work out.
It's just talk right now.
Yeah.
Good Front kicks to the body by Ferera.
Right.
Oh Nice.
I cut him up and sliced them up.
Nice.
One nasty cut and it's Oh beautiful tape down.
Yeah he's strong as fuck.
That's a big boy.
He is large is huge for one 85 it's almost hard to believe when you stand next
to him then he makes that weight.
Wow.
Cause I weigh 185 so how's that Guy Hunter?
It doesn't make any sense.
And I'm like you're a way bigger than me.
Andrew is fucked up man.
He's really bloody.
Okay.
That is something a lot of people ask me.
You know,
cause you know I've been in the sports since about 2001 ish,
2000 I guess.
And uh,
hey,
what's changed the most?
I go wait,
cutting has guys are so much bigger than they used to be that you should be.
Pretty much just wrestlers did that.
Now everybody does it.
Dude.
Andrew Craig is a mask of blood that is bad and it's right over the eye,
which is a bad place to get good irrigated.
He's trying to get back up
and say's there's got his back now defend that left hook.
Oh son,
I never have some ask you.
Have you ever had a cut roughly that nasty in a fight?
No.
Never.
I was always wondering if there's just,
cause it never really bothered me getting hit and I never really got cut that
bad.
But you see it cause you don't see what we're seeing.
You don't know where it is.
You don't know exactly how deep it is.
You can't see it.
And suddenly my eyes are full of blood.
It's just,
that's gotta be a moment you go,
oh shit.
That is a gap because that's a battle.
Cause you don't know how bad it is.
One time I still have stitches in my eye in practice.
Yeah.
But I just Bam.
And then we're looking at the ceiling just like,
ah,
I don't,
all I heard was had Chris,
this kid,
this Japanese kid is just,
it was freaky athlete.
Good.
Yeah.
Just jump knee me in the face when I was shooting and just last in my eye open.
It was just like,
I'm surprised it hasn't,
doesn't open.
It's still got stitches in it.
You can feel them.
So they did dissolve and it's one of those,
no,
this was the long time ago.
They were just never gonna pull out.
No,
I guess I'm supposed to do that.
Yeah.
That sounds good.
It was cause I was fighting soon.
And then this is left tomorrow.
Yeah.
By the way,
for,
it's got a nice run naked,
but he can extend his back because he's up against the cage.
Yeah,
that's a real problem.
But his hips into it.
Yeah.
That's the benefit of the,
the ring.
Oh No,
now he's got it.
Now I might be in trouble.
I can extend.
Well,
Andrew's actually scooting back.
That body triangle sucks.
A Fat Dick.
Doesn't that.
Ah,
for me,
I had me on.
They had me with that for the first round of our fight.
Worst feeling and he just,
I couldn't get him off.
I kept was impossible.
The worst is when a guy's got your back and your belly down.
That body triangle is locked in.
Just such a stretch for you,
Tony.
Frequent.
Yeah.
Tapped out to that.
Ivan salivary got 'em.
Another great example of that is,
um,
Anderson Silva beat High Alto Saccharine and had a by Joan.
She was beaten.
The dog should,
I haven't been shoot though for the old school fans.
He's switching it back as long time ago.
Man.
Ferraris keeps trying,
but Andrew Craig is not giving up me in a minute.
Sorry guys.
One of my favorites of all time.
Right y'all dude,
I love how it's a soccer.
That old school highlight.
Awesome.
Love it.
Dennett Dennett part willing over the garden.
Shit.
That was a fight that I was bummed out when he fought gummy and pride and he
came out with his leg.
All Mama fucked up and you knew he was fucked up.
He knew he was injured going into that fight
and he always got screwed at the head and arm throw.
He try and it like innocent Sylvia,
if you slip,
you get your back taken and you did that against Gomi did that again.
Silva,
same thing.
The Japanese use that they go out there to die.
Yeah.
I mean they are savages.
I was ring,
so it was before ever even worked for the UFC.
I was uh,
I was cage side when Matt Hughes fought them in the UFC and that was when it was
evident.
The difference between a guy who cuts weight,
he's a big strong wrestler and the guy who doesn't soccer,
I just did not belong in there with bad news.
Yeah.
Mad.
He was just mauled him.
It was just too big and too good at the time that's hanging on.
Oh
my goodness.
Head kicked him.
Okay.
This would be Khloe.
Jesus,
he's fucked up.
He's fucked.
Andrew Craig,
his game as fuck and
he cannot see the punches coming.
He can't see the right hand.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my God.
Can't let off the gas now,
but he doesn't have it.
He will lose the fight.
He's a lot.
He's a gave a pint of blood back there.
When you're sitting down.
Oh,
we tagged them again.
It's got to finish him.
You gotta finish him.
Jump on him.
There we go.
Keep landing that and fucking right hand
for our can.
Just jump guard right now.
You might just flop and jump guard.
He'll make it ready to wing that.
Ross didn't do it.
It's like here comes,
here comes the bed,
pull the trigger and time.
Wow.
I don't know.
That's interesting.
Wow.
You know the cut is one thing,
but you get past the cut.
Who did more damage.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean
it is a nasty cut,
but he also threatened with rear naked.
I mean not really.
It never looked like it was closed.
That was the closest that head kick and those combinations.
That's an interesting case.
As far as like judging around,
if I was going to judge that round,
I think I would be inclined to give it to him because he had kicked him,
had him rocked chasing him.
He was way closer to being ended.
Then a guy defending the back.
You know what guys?
Guys defend the back for a whole round and they're fine the next round,
he's not fine.
He got fucked up.
You know,
he got head kicked,
he got cracked.
But that's,
that highlights the real problem with a 10 point must boxing system being used
in MMA and not being even used correctly or the problem is,
is that the equal
criteria according to Muslim is,
is effective striking in a fit of grappling.
Well affective grappling doesn't cut a guy up,
doesn't leave a lot of marks.
Affective striking guys on roller skates.
It's ways you to see.
So yeah,
so judging wise,
it's very difficult to deal with.
Really difficult.
It's true.
Very true.
I've seen guys get school.
I mean that's,
you know,
the great thing about Jujitsu when we train it,
I mean you can go with a world champion.
All you do is tap a lot.
Yeah.
You know,
it doesn't,
if you go 10 rounds of mallet pet,
you know,
you're like glue in your limbs back together.
You know,
it just doesn't even in sparring.
So you know with grapple,
that's a great part of it is,
Oh shit,
I just got pinned a lot.
It was unfortunate.
But you're okay.
The next day I tell you a little bit because you have these two brothers from
the Arctic Jujitsu that train does strength conditioning with me and I'm like,
just stick with Jujitsu.
Don't we get beat up for a living,
don't have to worry about getting punched.
Hopefully your sport,
we'll take,
we'll start making you some money.
They're like,
we don't want to get punched.
I'm like,
good.
If you don't get to ask,
you
really want to fight him and May.
You definitely shouldn't fight MMA.
No,
you just,
you just shouldn't do it.
It's gotta be something that is an obsession to you and if it's not an obsession
to you,
avoided at all costs,
man.
Nice little surfer kids who were like eight or 10 and they just like,
yeah,
we just,
we just want to do too and surf.
I'm like,
there you go.
Sounds beautiful.
And say the Ferera for I probably deserved it.
Yeah.
Very interesting.
I think he's going to remember that last round though.
No,
very interesting.
Good fight.
And it shows how tough Andrew Craig is,
man.
Seriously tough as fuck here.
Oh,
they're showing the kick.
Oh no they're not.
That's just a straight left that took them down.
Yeah,
they all again move with a fight and all the guy who won.
Here's that elbow.
God Damn,
that was perfect.
That was beautiful.
That was like he hit him with a razor blade.
Lou.
That perfect.
And here's just power end technique.
Look at this rotation of the body,
the legs,
some core strength son.
Boom.
And you see that Gash is immediately Plickers glop.
A blood landed on his shoulder.
Amazing.
Who's like at an all time favorite fighters to watch.
Who's like your all time favorite fighter watch.
I think my all time favorite if I were to is how to Sakkara.
He was like my favorite finding shooto love watching that guy.
Loved watching him.
I think prime vandelays mine and I'm anyone's grand prime Vandelay was so
fucking crazy.
It was.
It was so wild.
Smiling,
stomping on the what I used to love when he would do this thing.
Oh,
don't get in a fight Lucy.
Oh fuck yeah,
man he was,
he was so mad dog.
Like when he fought rampage,
those two fights with rampage.
He was so mad dog.
Just mad dog need him 50 times.
He was so crazy.
It was so fun to watch him man,
when he was at his best.
He was just so ferocious,
so ferocious.
You know?
It's funny like Phil Baroni was talking about at once and he was like,
fucking let everybody do fucking steroids.
He goes,
I don't want to see choose to Vandelay back when he was in pride,
when he was at his best.
I was laughing,
but I was like,
part of me agrees with that.
Like as a fan,
just a fan of the spectacle of Vandelay Silva of Cro,
cop of the guys when they were at their best.
I know that was fun to watch.
Vandelay in his prime was fun to watch.
I know.
Who knows what he was actually on.
I'm just assuming we're not medical professionals.
We all know that people take things.
I mean,
he's a reason why this chill son and news is out.
There's a reason why it's not that surprising.
It's not like,
you know,
it's not the first thing he's cheated when people take things they just do.
And especially when you talked to a guy like ensign who tells you that no one
got tested and that the fucking contract said we will not test you force bat
roids and then in Brazil you can get steroids the same place you get gum.
Yeah.
I mean,
oh I'll take a pack of gum and fucking nozzle all.
Go ahead and throw that in there too.
Something with a horse on the label.
You mean that Oh,
Calvin gasoline and Nico Moose Soki he's gotten so good.
Fuck cashless.
Striking.
Fucking ridiculous.
The looseness of his striking his boxing against Rick story was really,
really impressive.
But fucking kids struggling to make weight.
And Mike Dolce is a motherfucker dude.
Like Joe Dolce took a picture cause after he lost,
he didn't make weight again and they asked him why stopped using dolce said
cause dolce was too expensive.
So dolce took a picture of him making weight easy at one 70 and then he wrote
Hashtag worth every penny,
which is a fucked up.
It's true.
But there's a moose.
Okay.
I've never seen this kid.
Oh He's good man.
Yeah,
I saw him for the first time.
Um,
last year.
Calvin gasoline though.
I'm wondering what it's going to be like with him coming off of that,
uh,
that loss or coming off of that,
um,
that weight cut.
Cause that's a hard wait.
Cut.
If that he didn't make,
he didn't make it promotionally.
And once again,
man,
if you're getting into this game promotionally it,
it makes you so hard to deal with it.
It makes you very,
they hate that.
Yeah.
I mean they hate that with a passion.
Very hard to promote a guy who does it make weight.
It's how much should we put behind this guy?
Don't know if it's getting on the scale and make it,
yeah,
it can really,
really kill your career.
It ruins irrelevance if a fight ruins it completely.
Yeah.
Well we,
we do,
we talked about it a little bit before,
but is there a way that you can have guys weigh in the day of the fight?
Is there,
I mean my thought I had a crazy idea.
It's not a good idea,
but look,
you could have an understudy like you,
like you know how they do at Broadway.
Like if a guy gets hurt,
the show must go on.
They have a guy who actually knows the role and he'll take the place if a guy
gets sick or something like that.
Like if a guy does not weigh in at a specific amount the day of the fight,
commentators don't have those by the way.
We've got to get on there whether we have a voice or not.
Yeah,
we don't get drunk.
I wouldn't do so good math with that.
You want to get old tire implement drug testing for MMA.
That's a wrap son.
It's been,
it's been great,
but it's over.
Um,
he fought a car.
That's who most,
okay fought.
And I saw him in,
in Manchester and Carmen and armbar actually it was a great fight up until that
too.
A ridiculous fight.
So understudies,
so if the guy doesn't make weight,
the other guy steps in.
Yeah.
So like the guy doesn't get any of his purse.
He gets no money if he doesn't make the weight.
So it seemed that he'd keep guys from doing stupid shit like trying to lose 30
pounds in a day,
you know,
which we've all seen,
we've all seen,
I saw Travis Luder,
I'm never seen a guy closer to death that went on to fight.
Never saw a guy looks so bad.
Travis Luder came in way overweight and tried real hard to make it.
But the first,
the first time he was like two and a half over and then he just,
he couldn't lose any more.
He tried really hard,
but he was so drunk.
Silva fight,
right?
Yeah,
it was.
So it was a non title fight and then he got stopped.
He got caught in a triangle and got elbowed.
He came close to winning that got full mountain,
the first round tremor that going God damn as Luther was a mother fucker,
he was one of those texts,
a strong dudes,
Texas,
tough guy do to learn Jujitsu and got really fucking good taking tournaments out
here.
Charles McCarthy here on Gracie,
Charles McCarthy,
who I really respected,
he beat here on Gracie really here on or hinder cause a big term out here and,
and he ended up winning it.
Luder end up winning it.
And I know here on an hinder when it,
I think you'd beat one of them.
Charles McCarthy was on the ultimate fighter.
When you look that up and confirm whether or not McCarthy said it was like
rolling with Laborio,
he said he's fucking good.
And that's an incredible compliment saying that he's like rolling with,
I'll pull it up.
Travis Luder.
Travis Luder Jujitsu.
Yeah.
It was like an invitational out here and he was a motherfucker.
Dude,
he's a motherfucker.
Just,
it gets trained too long with his own people took too long before he eventually
went to Jackson's.
And by then,
um,
he wind up losing the Sapo to uh,
what's his name?
Uh,
the guy who Tim Silvia or Tim.
I'm Tim Kennedy.
Knocked out in a half day on the tall.
Yeah.
Remember that guy?
Oh,
in the fight for the troops.
The troops.
I Dunno if they have this Jujitsu reg rich Franklin beat him up too.
Man on his waist.
Just had no gas at all.
But he had rich Franklin down and had them almost in an arm bar.
Travis Luder was a mother fucker.
I just didn't have good gas.
Yeah.
How found the towel was his last fight.
He got Kod and that was a 2010.
That's what gotten a towel into the UFC.
And before that he beat chasing Mcdonald.
He was a,
he's a beast man.
Yeah,
he was a beast,
but they caught up after the rich Franklin fight.
Just never quite reached his full,
full potential.
But he got guillotine by Matt Lindland.
[inaudible] was a motherfucker.
He was,
people forget how God Damn Good Matt,
when Lynn was,
he was those guys who was,
who was,
could beat anybody.
But man,
his style was just never fan friendly.
Yeah.
Madelyn's never,
well I don't know.
You know that fan friendly thing,
they say that about aspirin to,
to me,
if you're a fan,
you gotta be fascinated by everything.
I'm fascinated that I appreciate him.
He could take Douglas Lema down a rag doll.
I'm like that's all it is.
I might cut the leave.
Fuck what am I looking?
I couldn't believe it.
I'm a fan of that man.
I'm a fan of that.
You can't say that's not fan friendly cause I,
I was really bummed out when the asker in UFC thing didn't work out.
And when take Dana White said that ambient takes,
oh I disagree.
I think we have,
in order for a title to be legitimate,
you have to see how a champion stands up to any and all challenges that are
effective.
And just because it's not fan friendly doesn't mean it's not effective.
If it's effective,
if the,
the better guys going to fucking win,
you got to let him fight any way they want.
The problem is,
and,
and guys like us are the hardcore fans of sport.
Um,
well,
it's hard for hardcore fans to understand is we aren't the target market.
Everybody wants it on the mom and pop's of the world watching MMA and we aren't,
you know,
the,
the hawkers and I said to me all the time,
like,
you don't appreciate this.
I'm hardcore fan.
It's like they're not after you thereafter the radio,
Joe there,
they already have you.
No one's trying to get Jimmy Smith and Joe Rogan to watch him and me.
We're going to watch it anyway.
Yeah,
we're doing this for free.
Doing this for 40.
I'm on vacation watching MMA with Joe [inaudible].
Got To make me do it.
Oh my Soki just tagged him.
The top right hand moves.
So He's been hitting them with some high kicks over and over again just into the
forearms.
But you both know,
man,
forearms are not designed to take fucking hard Molokai knots.
Take a bat and swing that.
My people will see it at home though.
They go,
oh,
I blocked that.
No,
he's hurt.
Like that shit hurts.
Like that's one.
I think I kicked so
much and it keeps you from punching.
Your arms are fucked up for a while.
Like for a few seconds.
You don't want to throw a punch with that arm cause he's not feeling so good.
Hey,
don't want to punch.
He didn't want to move.
You don't want to move your leg.
Robbie Lawler and Ellenberger right off the bat
makes him check three or four of those with the,
with the forearms,
he blocks him.
But God Damn Lala was slamming those in and that's did fucks your arms up.
I see.
Muy Thai fighters man laying in the stories about bathtubs full of ice.
So like he came and you came and move at the end.
Well and those are the ones that you blocked.
I talked to.
Do you remember there was a dude named Shuki who used to be a trainer,
it Magiro gym and he worked with Stan longe.
Anitas remember when Stan the man long Janita as he broke Dennis Alexios leg.
And the first thing I will add kick Stan had ridiculous power in his leg.
Kicks and shook.
He used to hold pads for him.
And he was,
he had to get a hip replacement because of holding pads for Stan Lodge.
Anitas hold that leg pad on the leg and he would just take them on the hip bone.
Boom.
One of getting a hip replacement.
Look at Miss Soki.
Me Mom was hokey and Calvin are in an epic fucking battle.
Kevin's a piece,
dude.
I was so impressed when he beat Uriah Hall.
Yeah.
How much did you miss?
Wait by on this one.
Two pounds.
Yeah.
Looking for guillotine.
Oh Nice.
Okay.
Where's miss okay from Sweden.
Huge wrestling background.
Not
Late Calvin.
He's got his back.
So he's gotta be thinking the Kelvins fucking worn out from that weight cut.
That might be one.
The monomer lie.
Yeah,
he's pushing such a hard pace.
Cause Calvin barely made weight on the undercard of the Johnny Sanchez or Johnny
Hendricks fight that Johnny Hendricks,
Robbie Lawler fight.
He was one of the ones that also struggled to make weight.
Barely made it.
But again,
looked like he was on fucking death's door.
And that was back in Dallas.
Okay.
And when you think about,
if you're not around the fight world,
the whole lot,
if you think about everything you're losing for that two pounds,
that should be an indication about physically hard.
What you've gone through that you're like two pounds amount.
Yeah.
I just want 80% of his person,
20% of your fucking purse to walk away and just got,
I just can't do that.
And it goes to your opponent.
That fucking sucks.
It goes to the guy who's beating your ass right now.
It's just imagine how hard those last 10 pounds where they were awful.
Yeah.
Good control.
Both hooks in man.
Real good control.
Yeah.
Calvin,
who knows how he's feeling right now is if he actually missed the weight and
just gave up,
he must have been really fucking hurting.
Yeah.
Really.
Try and look at that fight night avail of the Donald Serone,
Jim Miller.
That fights coming up.
It's gonna be good.
That's another one that makes my hands sweaty.
Nico's uh,
like I said,
he's from Sweden,
one of Gustafson's buddies.
He's very well rounded,
super aggressive to what do they start with over there?
Martial art lives,
I think get my main,
I mean I don't,
I don't think they have like,
I mean I'm sure they have karate schools and I'm sure they have some white tie,
but they're just,
they're not,
they don't have a wrestling background and their educational system.
No.
I tried to explain to somebody in the MSN on air to belts are one time I said
America,
it's generally wrestling Europe,
they like kickboxing.
Brazil is Jujitsu.
That's generally the base.
People start out with Europe.
Kickboxing can make a living at it,
have slam.
They have a lot of good promotions out there.
Generally if they're from Europe kickboxing's where they start out.
Um,
yeah.
Great job with that left butterfly keeping old.
Calvin's turns him over and he's on top 15 seconds to go though.
You got to do some damage.
You want to win this round?
You can't just let them hold on to you.
Okay.
Huh.
And he will,
yeah.
Calvin's not getting anything off here.
Oh,
good.
Righthand Nice,
Nice Punch at the bell.
Yeah.
Europe generally.
Sambo.
Man.
It's amazing how many Samo guys are fucking starting to trickle into MMA now and
just dominate.
Does Russians or the Dagestani?
Yeah,
the Pakistani man.
Frightening place.
Fuck.
That is a hard place with charred men.
Uh,
okay.
When shallot,
some live was going to fart fight pattern for the belt packer and goes,
hey man,
you know someone's,
you know,
they have to kill me to take this belt away.
And he looked right at him and goes to,
sure.
I'm from Dagestan.
I,
it was hilarious.
It was like,
I forget what it was while doing what?
They were tired.
He goes,
you know,
soon as I have to kill me to take my belt,
like the general American,
he goes,
sure docusign.
It happens all the time.
You know what?
I made some joke about you don't know where I'm from,
Bro.
Yeah.
Kill somebody for something that nothing new.
That was some scary shit.
That's the ultimate.
You don't know where I'm fine.
You don't know where I'm from,
man.
From one of the worst places on earth to grow up and live.
Yeah.
I mean,
you could live in Africa,
in the jungle with leopards and shit.
I'll probably be worse.
Yeah.
Have you seen the,
every guy they interviewed was like head fucking cauliflower ear.
Yeah.
Like,
and the guy was like,
he's like,
it's not that we're terrorist.
He's like,
you killed my brother.
You killed my brother.
I'm gonna fucking kill you.
And he hadn't fucking gnarly ears.
I was like,
oh,
that's what you're doing.
You're pissing off a country full of wrestlers.
Yeah.
Kelvinn looks so good.
Good eyes fee.
So light on his feet.
And that's like,
that's something that he started getting after the ultimate fighter.
But again,
we Soki keeps landing that right kick over and over and over again into the sun.
Oh,
Calvin with a good straight laughed.
good combination.
Right.
Hook in a straight where number cut.
You know,
I think Calvin thinks he hurt Nico at the end of that round.
Those couple of shots jumping on and landed.
Yeah.
Good kick to the body.
Oh fuck.
He's all over him.
Got to get off the fence.
Promise he's going against the fences feeder squaring up.
Calvin is a fucking man.
That's a tough kid.
It's just for me,
it's a matter of him being healthy at this weight.
I think he can't do it.
If he uses a guy like dolce,
he's got a diabetic because you can just look at it and be like,
yeah,
he could.
He could lose some pounds.
I see a good five,
six pounds.
Yeah.
He just get with dolce bro.
Pay Him the money.
It's not,
it ain't 20% okay.
We lost 20% of your purse pay.
Daltry he knows his shit.
Yeah.
He gets everybody on weight,
everybody and they look great.
How about Tiago Elvis?
He had Tiago Alva as 170 pounds a day before the weigh in and looked at smaller
like look like you lost a little bit of muscle,
but man,
well rate gas tank moved.
Well and that's the difference.
It's like,
do you want to go Tyron Woodley where you're so big that you know you're super
explosive for like a minute and a half,
two minutes,
three minutes?
I think psychologically,
a lot of times for fighters,
it's kind of a security blanket to be big and swole and they don't feel that
there'll be able to win without it.
It's more like I,
the confidence of being the bigger,
stronger guy,
but it's not worth the trade off a lot of times.
It's not where it really is.
Losing your gas is the scariest thing ever.
Oh,
that's the worst.
Another person trying to beat you to death,
I'm tired.
Beat you to death.
Like there wasn't a reference there.
That person could kill you.
Yeah,
exactly.
Dolan was save him.
There's a,
there's a great story of George Foreman,
Muhammad Ali when they were fighting and Zaire and it's like,
you know,
the seventh or eighth round,
it's almost over,
and he goes,
I had nothing left,
I hit Ali with a good one,
a good body shot,
and I heard them go,
is that all you got?
And I remember thinking,
yeah,
that's about it.
That moment of going all right as,
ah,
fuck,
I'm out of gas.
That's the worst fuel Kelvin's all over him again.
Beautiful combination knee.
He hit him with an elbow,
caught him on the elbow with that foot though.
They'll have a hurt.
Oh,
another one took a body kick.
Good blocking to Kelvin has improved so much and change so much in the way he
moves.
That's Oh,
nice.
Step off to the side and throw that left kick to the body.
Foot works good.
That's what's setting everything up is he?
He's,
he's cutting enough angles that he can't see it coming.
He's also light on his feet,
which is a rarity in MMA.
That's a really important thing to have that mobility that you see so often in
boxing and karate and a lot of other martial arts,
but in MMA,
so many guys are trying to like Moy Tai it stand flat foot or wrestling
wrestling's very flat footed.
Yup.
Yeah.
The,
the accuracy rate on a 100% punches.
So slammed comparative.
You land for 50% chance.
Yeah.
He gets someone wobbled.
And the foot work that you're able to achieve by being light on your feet.
Like the Tj Dillashaw Hanan Barao fight were so light on his feet that Hennen
Browne never had a stationary target to load up on all this.
This spinning kicks.
He was always the same side.
Yup.
He was always pivot on the same side and he was falling.
I'm like an elevator door or like a,
I'm one of those revolving doors.
Yeah.
Just get in it.
Follow the door.
Calvin's all over him.
Now.
This is all about him off the fence either.
This is the Kelvin Gasol him round man.
He's put a beating on Nico,
so put to rest.
Any thoughts about him being completely diminished?
By the way?
Cut.
He's obviously got a lot in his fucking tank man and Nico's exhausted.
It's getting broken into.
That's the thing that,
you know,
they used to not test for EPO,
which is kind of hilarious because boxing,
the boxing commission,
they would say that boxing is not an endurance sport,
so you don't have to test for EPO.
Yeah.
Having never imagined spoken like someone who's never done it before.
There's that dumb and they're a part of the commission that's judging.
Yeah.
What gets passed and tested for,
and maybe it was like EPO is too expensive to test for EPO.
They developed a test and I want to say 2000 for Epo for the first time.
Uh,
that's what Lance Armstrong was doping with.
Shane Mosley plop for it,
man.
Moses got popcorn.
Yeah.
They've found some old blood of his and I'm like,
Hey,
let's give this a shot.
Oh,
it looks like a,
you got some weird blood dude.
It's 50% more blood cells in a normal person's blood.
Hmm.
How weird.
This has turned out to be a good fight though.
Very good.
Yeah.
I don't know what they're gonna do.
Um,
if they do wind up tests and everybody and they find out that the roster just
overrun with people that are on everything.
Yeah.
You know,
if they can,
if they can test.
You said there's too many people in MMA.
I didn't really say good way to call the herd.
My friend was asking,
I was asking
what do you,
uh,
I mean,
what do they do?
What do they,
what do they do if they find out like 60% of the people that cut 60% of the
Bible now,
how if they start
this procedure,
how long does it take to get there?
Your system?
Like how long will they,
it's a good question.
That's the question is if everybody cut now someone's already got to figure it
out too late.
Yeah.
I mean there's some fucking guy out there that knows his shit,
you know,
and it's like as listen to the ball.
Okay.
I talk about it.
There's always someone a step ahead because someone's got to,
someone's still got to sell that shit and figure everything out.
So it's,
it's,
you know,
like a guarantee.
Everything's already been
very well planned.
I wonder,
I wonder if there's a new thing that they can take now that you can't test for.
Lopers are always ahead of the system.
They have to be,
I mean,
by definition there,
because people have to do things.
That is the system that is the system is people do stuff,
they do stuff,
it's illegal and the the testers figure it out and catch them,
but they're always lagging behind.
You know,
it was originally made EPO for,
for leukemia patients that would have trouble keeping the red blood cell count
up.
So never occurred to them that somebody would take that in order to help their
endurance.
And then they started taking it now that'd make a test for it.
So that's the cycle.
They make it for something and then someone figures out how to cheat with it and
then they figure out how to catch him.
The catchers are the people who are trying to catch the people are always at the
end of the process.
I'm ignorant as to how it's all done.
So I don't know whether or not,
this is a stupid question,
but is there like a point in time where they run out of things?
There's,
there's no more things that you could add to the human body that they haven't
already discovered.
So there's no more things that you could add that they can't test for like that.
The clear stuff.
Part of w we had that guy on the podcast,
Victor Conte,
and he was talking about the whole ball call scandal.
And what I found really interesting about it was that he just had altered some
stuff and made it so it was not within their testing parameters,
but still effective.
Yeah.
At a certain point in time.
Did they run out of those variations?
I don't know.
I don't,
I find it hard to believe.
Um,
uh,
McKell Ferrara who was McKella Ferrari was a doctor who dealt with Lance
Armstrong and helped him through his tour de France wins of course,
helped him.
Dope was asked one time,
have we seen the limits of human endurance,
of the capacity for human endurance?
And he turned to the guy and he laughed and goes,
we're nowhere near it.
So I mean,
they're always going to come up with something because it's just,
it's going to be,
what I hear though is genetic engineering and I hear things like mio step,
whoa,
hi,
kick myostatin inhibitors and all the,
all the different shit that they're inevitably going to come up with down the
pipe.
But I wonder if like they're going to be able to come up with new steroids
because I think genetic engineering is a completely different ballgame.
Completely different.
But,
but no.
Also think about it.
I mean,
will there be a cure for cancer?
Yeah.
We can sit her and go,
yeah.
Eventually.
[inaudible] so they got to come up with something,
right?
It's like saying whether it be new stories.
Well,
will there be new medical advances for other things?
Yeah.
Then they're going to be new ways to improve the human body.
And I think we'll be playing this game probably the rest of our lives.
Yeah.
I wonder,
I wonder they have robots doing this shit until it's like the Fox intro in real
life.
Like fuck fucking robot.
Uh,
no,
you do had to bring that up.
I hate those fucking robot goofy picking up robots and slam.
And I'm like,
what looks like a transformers commercial?
Well,
that movie,
remember that Mighty
uh,
Wolverine Guy,
Jack Knew Jackman.
There was robot fighters.
Woo fucking funded that movement.
That shit is so terrible.
Oh,
Calvin threw a kick in the slip.
Been in this fucking octagon,
man,
especially with logos.
Do you find a difference in certain logos being more slippery than others?
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah,
it's different surface.
But I mean you're,
you,
I get this weird heightened sensation in my feet when I'm out there and moving
and like I,
if I just step on that canvas,
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
I got Boehner in my feet,
get all tingling and I'm just dancing and I just feel this.
It's,
it's a weird,
but yeah,
you do feel a
definite,
especially if it was blood on it and blood is the body's best lubricant,
you know,
like that's the fucking,
that shit gets on something
very slippery.
It's why it's interesting when guys get caught,
it actually makes them easier to choke.
Can wait,
slide things under their chin easier.
This a good fucking fight.
Calvin's come on strong.
Nice body shots.
Ooh.
Whipped that right hand to the body.
Okay.
And that's what I mean guys cooked,
they make these horrible cuts and they perform great.
It's just,
I mean it's just hard to say,
come on motherfucker.
He's got a brown great.
His back's up against wall.
The UFC fucking hates it when guys miss.
Wait,
every,
I mean Belterra it's it too.
This is third.
They hate it.
I don't think he missed weight last time he made it.
He just needed a second attempt.
No,
I know he did and that was there.
Uh,
but this is his first.
We fought at one 85 on the show and so he's fighting at one 70 here.
He's a one 71 70,
but he's got to do it more,
more correctly and more with more discipline.
Oh,
high kick.
But he's still a bad mother fucker.
Dude.
Is those two high kicks in a row suite and he still has good footwork for the
beginning of fight to the end of the fight.
Good footwork.
Very good.
Yeah.
Light on his feet.
He's keep racking that thing.
Yeah.
Woo.
And they were exchanging them back and forth.
Something big and fighting.
Don't set a pace.
You can't keep something in the first round you can't do in the third round.
Great.
He kept it up all three rounds.
Yeah,
he did.
And Move Soki didn't.
Interesting fight man.
Interesting fight.
I wonder who got that.
I think that that's the one thing that goes through my head.
The most of the fight is don't stop moving.
Stop moving.
Don't stop moving.
I kicked,
I landed 43 lake kicks I think.
I think a area,
hold on.
He said my last fight that was just legs.
I kicked him in the body and the head a little bit but I mean Atlanta at 43 I
and the whole time I was just going
good.
I think I landed one every 20 seconds they broke it down.
I was always thinking if I'm hitting him he's not hitting me.
Yeah.
Like if I just keep hitting him,
make him miss to make a mess,
man.
That's awesome.
Keep it up.
It's just to keep,
keep doing the angles and footwork.
What,
what is the best thing for strength and conditioning for that?
Is there any one thing,
is it fight training or is strength and conditioning like just as important as
fight training when it comes to that with the way the athletes are in this sport
now it's strength.
Conditioning is huge.
And I mean we just,
we just kind of started putting it out on the Internet.
Um,
maybe these 50 gallon barrels,
you know,
I,
my,
my coach Corey Beasley at fight came conditioning.
You know who John Brookfield is?
He's the guy who started the,
the ropes and the towels and all the shit and he started listing strongest grip.
He's just some little Walrus who's pulls trucks and shit,
you know,
but he's kind of given this,
given this barrel idea,
the Corey and you put 500 pounds of sand in a big plastic barrel and you push
and push and pull and kind of roll it.
You can check it out on my Instagram.
Um,
uncle creepy MMA and you just,
you know,
you just roll this thing back and forth and it's,
it's fucking it.
I've never had something made me so strong in my entire life,
but I mean,
obviously besides wrestling,
but
there's no,
you can't,
you can't not have the training drilling.
You have to Joe something 10 that you want to mass master anything.
You have to drill it for 10,000 hours.
It's true.
You know you have to do everything and we've got so much shit to try and master
that.
But that sounds crazy.
So you're,
you're grabbing this giant barrel and what are you specifically trying to do
with it?
Think about from a clinch,
you know how like Johnny Hendricks huge though,
right?
Can you even get your arms around it?
There's a top on it.
Okay.
And then you sit there and you,
you grab it and you grab it here and you twist it.
So you've got 500 pounds that you're twisting back and forth or you're pushing
and pulling in all the muscles throughout the whole part of it are,
I mean the first couple of times you do it,
you're like,
Holy Shit.
Wow.
I don't think I've ever used these muscles before.
Let me pull it up for you.
It's fucking,
I'm trying to find it.
I'm on your Instagram right now.
Kelvin.
Gaslin when's the decision?
It's a now give that money to dolce son.
Yeah,
call dog.
I was like,
you got a cool picture of your daughter getting into the cryo thing.
That's,
you got it.
Oh,
he's got it up here,
here at pull it up,
give it to us in large size and we go and there's a,
there's a video of it too.
And so that's 500 fucking pounds.
Yeah,
that's the sand.
There's one of water too.
That's um,
oh my God,
check this.
Where's the videos routine?
It's a little bit down.
How far?
How long ago did you put it up?
A couple of weeks.
Couple of weeks ago.
You a daily Instagrammer guy?
Yeah,
I'm an Instagram whore,
but I don't,
I don't run a,
I'm,
there is other people that do post things on my Instagram,
my Facebook,
my Twitter.
So if I don't fucking say,
you know,
thanks for,
if people fucking send me private messages all the time and I,
right.
So I have a real hard time keeping up this,
this,
this hip workout you're doing.
It's giving me some would bro.
I'm not gonna lie about it.
Like not,
not even,
I mean,
that's,
you know,
granted my girlfriend only weighs like 95 pounds.
I get out,
Jo,
I'm passing the word on to you and you said,
yeah,
go ahead.
Interest man would though split.
She was not gay.
It's totally different.
So this is just a sequence that you go through.
Wow.
This hip escape thing that you're doing with the weight on you.
How much weight is that?
I don't know.
It looks like a lot of weight.
You gotta I dunno.
It looks like,
oh,
it's up there.
I fuck,
I don't know.
It's a lot of weight.
I'm Kinda,
I don't know.
I've gotten kind of strong.
I live,
I say like whatever.
I don't even know dude.
You could do it.
I don't even know Bro.
I've been working with Kuwait for a long time.
He tells me what to do.
It looks like a 45 to 30 fives and a 25 what does that 41 to 41 45 in each size.
One 35 to two 35 hours or two is right to 35 25 that's a lot of fucking weights
on.
That's a lot of weight.
And that's a normal limpic barbell,
right?
Yeah.
Jesus Christ kid.
That's gotta be really good
for your fucking back.
You're back in core.
Must be tremendously strong.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
it's fun and it's,
you know,
it's,
it's something that we're trying to,
you know,
everyone's in the crossfit and crossfit cool or whatever,
but what would his crossfits know?
Cross training across different types of exercise.
Exactly.
It's,
you know,
it's what I like to do and I've gotten good at it and we've kind of built the
system and,
um,
but yeah,
and again,
the barrels is the toughest thing that I've,
I've never felt something made me so strong.
Wild.
I love that,
that thing that you're doing up there with the weight too,
because that lifting the hips up like that,
first of all,
drastically increase your ability to send it home on a check,
right?
Dude?
Yes.
Harder than uncle creepy.
Have you saw thinking,
have you seen it grow?
You see my girlfriend,
you got to send it in,
but gal happy.
Ooh,
look at this next cub Swanson.
Jeremy Stevens.
Five rounds to if it goes,
I think it'll go five rounds.
No,
I don't think so.
If I know Jeremy Stevens rock in a crazy Amish beard,
uh,
yeah,
I probably won't go five rounds,
but that,
um,
that's gotta be tremendous for your ground game when it comes to like hip
escapes and things like that,
to have that ability to pop up off the strength of that.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
My fighting guys 125 pounds and you're doing that with whatever the fuck that
was,
however much weight that was.
Yeah.
It was,
uh,
you know,
that's something that,
that actually we,
I was talking to my toe,
the anet guys about taking,
doing the takeover thing and then trying to do,
instead of like cub did just,
just him,
I was thinking of doing me and strength conditioning stuff because it's all,
it's on it kind of stuff.
But,
uh,
that's,
that's our new,
my thing.
We'd say,
I just fight came conditioning.
It's,
it's fun and it's,
you know,
it actually,
we,
it,
it fucking works.
Obviously.
I,
you know,
if someone weighs 125 pounds,
I'm gonna fucking sent him for a ride.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think what you had there was 325 pounds,
wasn't it?
I can text,
let's,
let's figure it out because it's one 45 plate on each side with an Olympic
barbell is 135 pounds.
Right?
Right.
And then you add to 30 fives on each side,
which is one 40 to that.
So you have two 75 and then you have two 20 fives on that as well.
So that's another 50 pounds.
Yeah.
So that's 325 pounds.
That's fucking crazy.
That's a lot of God damn wait to fuck.
You know,
if you had a big girl on top of you,
she's like,
motherfucker,
you can't send it in
her up while you're fucking from the bottom.
She'd be like,
damn,
that little white boy.
Fuck me.
Right.
I just,
I don't know why I made her a black chick.
I don't know why I just throw that big.
I just automatically think they're best.
What I think
I let my lecture all the work,
I don't know.
You guys didn't need all these weights and shit.
Listen,
you know,
sometimes I don't what I'm saying.
I'm not all Dick.
I got,
I'm like,
I love
my Dick.
Do all the work.
I don't need his hip exercise shit.
A Cub Swanson has got one of the wildest,
most
unpredictable styles of his fight with Dennis Seaver.
Yeah.
The last combination when he,
when he had him hurt,
it was so fucking accurate and just ridiculously wild.
Like real wild,
but super accurate.
Explosive Man.
He does all of his strength and conditioning.
What balancing.
He'll do like weightlifting stuff while he's standing on balls and stuff,
you know,
like those um,
those uh,
what are those balls?
This is called an a medicine ball.
No balance balls to the wall,
plyo balls,
whatever you call him.
But he does all that stuff.
Like a little stand on half balls and do like kettle bells,
like everything he does,
he's doing with uh,
with balance.
Jeremy.
Steve.
It's a motherfucker though.
That kid,
he has heavy handed man.
He is hard.
He hits hard.
He hit artist as a lightweight,
as a one.
He kept all that power going to 45.
And that's,
that's a rare thing.
While he's healthy,
he's doing it real good.
Alliance is a serious fucking team man and he,
he fucking knocks people out over there all the time.
Does he really?
I mean he's,
he's,
he's a lot of fun to hang out with but he,
he's a fucking savage in the gym.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
He's an interesting guy to talk to.
I enjoyed talking to him.
Mark Smart Guy.
Yeah.
I had him on the podcast.
He was great.
He's a,
he's an interesting dude,
but his fucking power is redonkulous but cub is to so awkward.
Kenny deal with the angles and the explosive.
That's the question.
Yeah.
Tuck comes a wild man.
I would like to see where you match your covers is,
although,
you know,
yeah,
I mean although caught him,
you can't blink to ill double flying me.
Jesus.
It is what it is.
You know,
you get hit with that.
That's a wrap.
Your head split open.
I mean he covered up immediately,
had a big ass scar,
but I would like to see what would happen if that fight.
Well that was a different cub.
Swanson then too.
I mean,
although was at its peak then you still,
I don't think although has diminished at all.
Everyone else has gotten better.
Yeah,
he's slowed down a little bit and because he takes it,
he plays it a little bit more safe because he's got so much to lose and he's
alone and he's bigger.
He's gotten very,
yeah,
it's a big,
I don't think the dude wants to go to one 55 because if he goes to one 55 he's
not going to have his title is title means a lot.
You know,
being a world champion means a lot and as long as he can make the weight,
it's going to be real hard.
Unless they have like some sort of a super fine.
Now,
if they had a super fight and it was,
if I went on this five pound champ,
I lose,
I'm still the 45 pound champ.
I think he'd take that.
Yes.
I think that's the way to do it.
I think that's the way to get them in.
But you know when a guy's like a guy like Aldo man,
he's a fucking hero in Brazil.
He's a hero.
He's a huge star and as a mixed martial artist man to be a world champion is
where it's at.
Yeah,
he is a world fucking champion.
[inaudible] that's the one thing man,
that fucking weight cut.
He would,
he,
if he went 55 once,
I don't think he would go 55 again.
Really?
Cause I mean he just seems like he just gets,
he,
he would put on too much,
too much weight and then it would just be fucking death to get down.
But like it wasn't hard before.
Once you taste what it's like to not cut that.
Yeah,
it's hard to get back down again if he tasted what it's like to feel good when
you're actually inside.
Yeah.
It could be a good change.
You never know.
It could be because I think there's a good chance against pedes.
I think he has a good chance and that fire,
you know,
else has a good,
a chance to have fight pedis
pedis as a good job.
Why?
It's a great fight.
Although it goes up and gets Kol by Pedis,
you know,
but pedes said he could make one 45 man,
he said he could make it a pet.
This is not a huge 55.
No,
no.
He's not fucking slick man.
Jesus really good on the ground too.
That's what people sleep on when he caught Henderson with that arm bar.
I mean that was a standard Bjj one o one on bar in the middle there some quick
but done well done.
Perfectly.
Nice adjustment.
He changed the angle,
which is what a blue belt.
I think they were saying it's a purple belt and it was just a,
it was a fucking basic drilled and yeah,
just,
it's why they do it that way.
Yeah.
It's like,
that's why we do it like that.
He's just fast as fuck man.
He's fast as fuck with everything.
But he tore his patella tendon and he tours LCL and had it all stitched back up
and shit.
But you know,
that's why he's doing this ultimate fighter with Gill.
It gives some time,
give us some time to heal,
get it all back in order.
And then,
uh,
eventually fight Melendez for the title,
which will be a very fun fight.
Yeah,
it's gonna be awesome.
Gilbert's a fucking beast.
But that,
that,
you know,
Gilbert,
that shows you how crazy he is.
Cause he could have fought Diego Sanchez in a safe way.
Yeah.
He could've just kept Diego at bay and to Mexicans.
Nope.
That was,
that was just,
you know,
I mean,
it's not being racist.
I'm Mexican.
My PSOAS,
Spanish,
same difference.
Nothing wrong.
Ooh,
down.
They're both proud Mexicans.
I mean,
that's what he said when I interviewed him after the fight.
He's like,
that's how Mexicans fight.
It's true.
You go fucking wrestle at Santa Ana high school like I did getting ready for
masters and shit.
Those are some fucking,
those are some,
some fucking mean kids.
However they got the shit out of each other.
Yeah.
Calvary Chapel,
Santa Ana and they studs,
they fuck each other up so bad.
That's where Eddie Bravo Bro grew up Santa Ana and it's a small little place,
but there's some rough fucking people.
I'm from Long Beach,
man.
Fuck.
I know.
You get excited when you hear.
Oh yeah.
Snoop Dogg song and went to my high school.
Did he?
Long Beach,
poly high school man.
Homeless scholars and criminals.
Good ass fuck scholars and criminal.
It's a whole homo scholars in champions,
but that's not what it good fucking homeless dogs.
Yeah.
Number one,
NFL producing high school in the country.
Really more NFL players went to long pilot in any other high school in the
country.
That's incredible.
Why is that?
Their football program is fucking amazing.
That's fucking fucking incredible.
From the offer for like 30 years.
It's been amazing.
Yeah.
Wow.
40 years actually.
How wild.
Yeah.
It's an old school.
It's
been around since like I was a hundred graduating class.
Fuck yeah.
1895 yeah.
In growing up in Newport.
What does it like being around all those yachts?
Is it hard?
It's a rough dude,
bro.
Everybody had a Mercedes.
We had Alexis.
Every time you were in front of an old restaurant,
it's,
let me throw you the keys and go Parker where I can see it.
Some shit.
Only dark dude.
You just can't trust him.
I know you want to give him your keys,
your car buck and white people man.
Pretty it's so,
it's beautiful.
It's South Orange County is the,
it's the California with white people and,
and you know what I live,
I live in the southern most part,
other San Clemente now in second in command,
you're homeless in San Diego.
It's fucking Sanko Minis,
the last good family town,
Orange County.
Cause it's just surfing and family.
And then for anyone my age that wants to be hip and cool and fucking work for a
cool company,
go live in Costa Mesa.
Costa Mesa is a good spot.
I mean there's the food,
there's a fucking incredible and there's ass everywhere if you're a guy out and
just,
it's a lot of good jobs and cool people.
No Shit.
Well Orange County is pretty bad ass.
It's just the traffic is so ridiculous because La is so good.
Right?
Well once you get there,
but once you get there like people just stay there cause it's like you can't go
anywhere.
Getting from Orange County up to here as a fucking joke.
My Dad did it for 39 years.
He drove it down to downtown La from fucking pill both ways in the snow.
He had no brakes.
He had to holes in the floorboards and stuck his feet up.
I
had a bunch of built supers did he?
Yeah,
for we can be on the fucking title dealerships.
So you drove up here and then we had built Porsche.
What's a more reliable car?
The super fucking 1200 horsepower on the stock transmission.
Amazing.
Those cried off pop.
I had a super,
that was the first good car.
Had no other fucking incredible and there's still the 97 was the last year of
the turbo 98 and it's still,
you can get the thousand horsepower to this fucking things and they look great.
Yeah,
there's still a cool looking car.
You see a super would that big crazy wind.
Ooh.
Pushing around like a shopping cart.
I loved that car.
Loved that fucking car.
Cub Swanson ready to step into the octagon.
God Damn.
I'm looking forward to this for some.
You get one.
You don't want to see this right here and you're going to leave.
You're going to be going to do,
man.
I got it going out in the lobby.
You got play with a woman to ride the Werewolf.
Everyone's afraid of it.
He's fucking fired up.
I love that movie.
Yeah.
American world from where I'm calling from London is when my favorite horror
movies of all time.
It's one of the all time greats.
It's amazing.
Remember silver bullet?
That was a great one too.
Well,
the young Corey Haim due to the young Corey Haim here before the dress and
peace,
Bro.
Lost Boys.
Don't get me started.
I'm going to watch fighting.
Corey Feldman's holding up the flag.
Yup,
man.
He is.
He's,
he's keeping it strong.
The core is alive.
The one core together to Cory's doing.
Oh Man.
Just like a fucking bill and Ted.
Whatever happened at Ted or bill,
whoever the other
Alex winter is his name.
He's in Los Boys.
Those are basically only two moves you then I'm serious.
You know that I,
I remember names.
That's amazing.
It was Marco and the lost boys.
You've got you use the first day.
I'm probably got killed and he did.
He did.
Uh,
I commend you for that.
Thank you sir.
Please.
That's some deep trauma.
Come from a trivia family.
So that shit out.
I loaned it directed by Joel.
It's just directly by who had a fuck do you know?
Just amazing that that guy remember weird shit.
That's part of the reason I'm in MMA,
I guess.
Actors of all time.
And he was in this big movie with that dude.
So you would think like,
well,
both these guys going to go on to bigger and better winter did not separate us
separately.
Want was his band.
You ever see fucking calories band and he was dog dog.
So he was trying out for a while.
I can just fucking playing the bass.
All fucked up looking.
Yeah.
He had a band for a while,
right?
He has so much matrix money.
He didn't know what to do.
Million dollar.
No.
What the fuck do I do?
I'm going to start a band.
Oh it do I need to,
there's a documentary.
Jared Leto did a documentary on his issues with being in a band and money and
like must be rough.
No,
no,
no.
What is it called?
Jamie?
Fact artifact.
That's what the band,
the movie,
the movie is called about his band.
We had some huge struggles.
Is that the movie about the financial issues with getting sued for $30 million?
Fuck,
by whom?
Record?
Company label.
It's like apparently it's crazy.
They way they do math like they do.
It's just fun off the so,
well I've heard it before like Courtney love wrote a whole piece on at once
about the way they do the accounting so that you never,
it never looks like they've made money so they never have to pay you.
Like the only way you make money is when you're touring.
That's when you make money.
But record sales go almost entirely to the record company and themselves and
they have their own wacky ways of deciding.
You know,
it's like Hollywood,
Hollywood.
What I've heard a lot is is any money they spend on promoting your album,
they consider it a loss and they'll call all these scenes promotional expenses,
so it's everybody you're paying basically for everybody who works for the label
because that's rational expense for your album.
Hilaire I've heard that a lot.
That shit as Lucas too.
I saw them
the first time I saw him,
they sounded great.
Jared led it signage,
just fucking awesome.
Then I saw him at Tahoe and they can,
he was trying to sing on his own without like auto tune or something and sound
flux.
I left.
You walked out and then they were terrible.
They were so bad.
It was awful.
When in doubt,
use autotune son.
Okay,
here we go.
Chairman Stevens and Cub Swanson.
Ooh.
Cub is quick man and he keep,
keep that quickness up for three rounds.
The real question is can you keep it up for five?
You know,
he's got such a explosion based style where he leaps in a lot with shit.
Okay,
Jeremy with a good kick there.
Ooh,
Jeremy Hits so fucking hard.
Everything's your tire flat.
Everything Jeremy does is heavy.
His kicks in,
his punches are very,
very heavy.
He's got a very good chin too.
Very rarely do you see him get stunned.
I mean,
he got knocked out by Eve Edwards,
but eve just caught them perfect and caught him when he was running in,
you know,
he was attacking and eve,
just time to right hand is perfectly placed hook
and that was what facilitated him going down to one 45
but you know anybody who lost three in a row at that point.
Yeah,
yeah.
Anybody running in to something and he just,
you know,
shit happens.
Like,
like uh,
Benevidez and mighty mouse,
mighty mouse.
It's very rare that mighty mouse knock guys out with one punch.
But Benevidez just walked into it and boom,
he hit me with the same exact punch.
I ran into the same shit.
Knock me down.
I mean,
didn't knock me out,
but yeah,
he's,
he,
he's very quick,
very quick.
Ridiculously quick.
Yeah.
We were talking about Simon Marcus and Joe Schilling.
That's a perfect example that you ran out of trying to get that point back
because they took a point away from him for the mouth guard and Schilling just
caught him.
Perfect.
There was two in that Wayne Barrett,
same thing.
The guy was chasing after him.
He caught him in mid air with a hook dude.
That was fucking night.
Like watching duck hunt.
Yeah
man.
Yeah.
Literally flying me out of the sky with the hook.
I started the guy next to me.
I was like,
it looks like,
uh,
what feed Orlowski man in the air.
One second down your face the next.
That's why the flying knee is so wacky.
You know Duke Roufus Gate perfect commentary on that too.
It was like,
you know,
you feel like you're a mortal.
You just kind of flying neither guy,
but you don't realize you're just,
you're fucking,
your face is flying towards his fist to,
so Jeremy's been landed some good clean,
right hands.
I like his leg kick.
Started riding with them.
Hard kicks and hard punches too.
And you could see cub is,
he's well aware that Jeremy's throat.
UHHH,
fucking slick.
Cartwheels.
One Hand because I'm a gangster.
He's tries to rolling thunder shit with the round kick.
I'm not going to lie.
I've been trying to lay the,
it's kind of fun and never landed.
I just throw it in people's directions.
Well,
okay.
This has been trying that allowed to,
according to Duke,
I don't even think I've ever been brushed anyone's hands that just fucking
throat and they're like,
will you ever see Brian ever saw throw that cart wheel kick?
He loves that rolling thunder kick.
He does it really well too.
And he did it in a fight once ever.
Salt did and they thought it was a fix.
They were going to find him and they were talking and they thought it was a fake
fight because they thought that that technique wasn't real.
That's how dumb some of these fucking people that are buying these athletic
commissions are.
It's essentially like a spinning ax kick.
Yeah,
I mean that's what it's like.
There was a guy,
a motor guy,
Sanchez sore kink store who's credible and he'll do that one handed.
I saw him hit a dude in Holland from
knocking right back there.
We just caught cub glip to nice right hand Sanchez,
it fucking,
and he's obese and he's not built like your average ties short and stocky and
just tosses crazy fast push kicks.
So good to watch those high level ties go out at two.
When you see like just the fluidity of the kicking technique and the speed of
the motions and you just see that next level striking.
Yeah.
It's fucking frightening.
What I like is Jeremy's throwing hard.
You can tell,
but he's still on balance.
He's not losing his foot work over it.
Good kickback cub there.
Yeah.
This is a high level fight man.
And the winner of this fight easily could be the next guy in line at one 45.
Yeah.
You know Jane,
I don't,
I mean I'm not saying it,
but they said to um,
to Jeremy that if he won he could be a short of a child shot or something like
that in some interview.
But honestly it doesn't mean anything.
It only,
I mean it's nice for the good right hand by cub.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
caught the kick.
Let's see what cub does off his back.
It goes right to butterfly cops.
Got a fucking black belt man.
Yeah,
he used to coach my nephew out in palm springs,
a teen.
He's holding on to that neck,
man.
Jeremy's got to be careful if he scoots his butt out,
scoots his out and gets a good grip on that neck.
He's passing his right arm through.
What's he doing on his right arm?
Is it a position where you can sweep or go over the head for the neck?
This is going to watch both and he keeps
his hips back.
But I,
I like to wear,
oh he's now he's holding.
Hey,
what did you doing?
Fox?
What's going on here?
Oh,
that's the round the rounds over.
What does that,
and this isn't creepy commercial too,
where like if I'm going to look like that,
do I really want to begin this sport?
Yeah.
We're going to turn into a pumpkin after this round.
Oh,
we really,
should we push it?
Yeah.
We're going to have to,
uh,
we're three hours in,
so this fight must be going long.
Is that what's going on?
Yeah,
it's already 10 o'clock.
We've got less than six minutes left on it.
Wow.
Okay.
Well let's,
let's shut off and come back on because it's in between rounds.
I live the audio,
so the audio,
we'll just keep running the way it is.
So focused on Ustream.
We'll be right back.
Okay.